Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On September 12, 1993, the claps family were preparing for a relaxing Sunday ahead. It was a sunny day in their hometown of Patenza, a mountain city in the Basilicata region of southern Italy. Parents Antonio and Filomena were looking forward to spending the day off from the tobacconist they ran in the centre of town and had travelled to the family's rural property,
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。1993年9月12日，克拉普斯一家正准备迎接一个轻松的星期天。这是他们家乡波坦察的一个晴朗的日子，波坦察是意大利南部巴西利卡塔大区的一座山城。父母安东尼奥和菲洛梅娜期待着享受他们在镇中心经营的烟草店的假期，并前往了家庭的乡村房产，
27 kilometres south west of Patenza, in the small village of Tito. Whilst it was only a basic and modest abode, their country house provided a haven to escape the hustle and bustle of the city and the family cherished the quality time they were able to spend together there. They looked forward to their Sunday lunches, filled with lively conversation and home cooked meals. Devout Catholics, the claps were well liked within their local parish and were a warm and loving family who supported each other at every turn. This particular Sunday, Antonio and Filomena were joined in Tito by their second-born son, 20-year-old Luciano. The trio were preparing lunch in anticipation for the arrival of the
位于波坦察西南27公里处的小村庄蒂托。虽然只是一处简陋的住所，但他们的乡间别墅提供了一个逃离城市喧嚣的避风港，一家人非常珍惜在那里度过的美好时光。他们期盼着充满热烈交谈和家常饭菜的周日午餐。作为虔诚的天主教徒，克拉普斯一家在当地教区很受欢迎，是一个温暖而充满爱意、在各个方面都互相支持的家庭。这个特殊的星期天，安东尼奥和菲洛梅娜在蒂托迎来了他们20岁的二儿子卢西亚诺。三人正在准备午餐，等待着
remaining two claps children, eldest son, 24-year-old Gildo, and the baby of the family, 16-year-old Elisa. The pair were due to arrive just after midday, along with one of Elisa's friends, Eliana Desilis. Back in Patenza, Elisa claps dressed in blue trousers, a white sweater knitted by her mother, and her trademark thin-rimmed designer glasses. She kept her thick, dark hair out and flowing below her shoulders. The bubbly teenager was popular amongst her peers, who were drawn to her warm smile, sense of humour, and kind-hearted personality. As the youngest of the claps children, she was doted on by her family, which contributed to her caring and compassionate nature. Although some noted, Elisa could be a little naive at times. Actively involved with her church, Elisa sang in the
其余两个克拉普斯家的孩子到来，即24岁的大儿子吉尔多，以及家中老幺、16岁的埃莉萨。这两人本应在中午刚过时到达，同行的还有埃莉萨的朋友埃利安娜·德西利斯。在波坦察，埃莉萨·克拉普斯穿着蓝色长裤、一件她母亲织的白色毛衣，戴着她标志性的细边设计师眼镜。她留着厚厚且垂过肩膀的深色长发。这位活泼的少女在同龄人中很受欢迎，大家都被她温暖的笑容、幽默感和善良的性格所吸引。作为克拉普斯家最小的孩子，她备受家人宠爱，这也造就了她富有爱心和同情心的性格。尽管有人注意到，埃莉萨有时会显得有点天真。埃莉萨积极参与教会活动，她在
Cathedral Choir and studied hard towards her passion of becoming a doctor, with her dream to one day work in Africa for a not-for-profit organisation. At 11am, the doorbell rang at the claps flat in Patenza. It was Elisa's friend, Eliana. The two had arranged to attend Sunday morning mass together at the Church of the Holy Trinity in the city centre. They planned to return to Elisa's home afterwards, before departing to the country for lunch with the remainder of the claps family. Elisa told her brother Judo that they would be back soon, and the two girls headed out towards the church. When an hour passed and the teenagers still hadn't returned to the flat, Judo started to worry. His sister was known for her punctuality and always phoned home if she
大教堂唱诗班唱歌，并为成为一名医生的梦想努力学习，她的梦想是有朝一日能去非洲的一个非营利组织工作。上午11点，波坦察克拉普斯家公寓的门铃响了。来的是埃莉萨的朋友埃利安娜。两人原本约好一起去市中心的圣三一教堂参加周日早上的弥撒。他们计划事后回到埃莉萨家，然后出发去乡下与克拉普斯一家的其余成员共进午餐。埃莉萨告诉她的兄弟吉尔多，他们很快就会回来，两个女孩便朝教堂走去。当一个小时过去，两个少女仍然没有回到公寓时，吉尔多开始担心起来。他的妹妹以守时著称，如果
was running late. Then the doorbell rang, and Judo found Eliana standing there alone. The teen told him she and Elisa had become separated at the church. Eliana assumed Elisa had returned home without her, and was surprised to learn she wasn't there. Concerned, Judo walked towards the city centre whilst keeping an eye out for his sister, before arriving to the Church of the Holy Trinity. The surrounding area was busy with crowds of people, but there was no sign of Elisa. As 2pm approached, and Judo and Elisa still hadn't arrived for lunch in Tito, the rest of the claps family decided to leave the food they had prepared and make the brief
快迟到了总是会给家里打电话。接着门铃响了，吉尔多发现埃利安娜一个人站在那里。这个少女告诉他，她和埃莉萨在教堂走散了。埃利安娜以为埃莉萨没有等她就径直回家了，得知埃莉萨不在家时感到很惊讶。吉尔多感到不安，一边四处寻找妹妹，一边朝市中心走去，最后来到了圣三一教堂。周围挤满了人群，但根本没有埃莉萨的踪迹。随着下午2点临近，吉尔多和埃莉萨依然没有到达蒂托吃午餐，克拉普斯一家的其他人决定放弃已经准备好的食物，做简短的
journey back to Potenza to see what was going on. When they returned, they were shocked and distressed to learn that Elisa had gone missing. Judo had already recruited a bunch of his friends to scour the area, but their efforts had failed to yield any results. Judo pressed Eliana for the exact details of Elisa's last known movements that morning. Eliana eventually admitted she hadn't been completely honest. The two girls had never intended to attend mass together. It had been a cover so Elisa could meet with a friend, 21-year-old dental student, Danilo Restivo. Elisa was reluctant about the meeting, as she knew Restivo had unreciprocated romantic feelings for her, and she found him quite odd. But he had been persistent, as he wanted to
行程返回波坦察看看发生了什么事。当他们回去时，惊恐地得知埃莉萨失踪了。吉尔多已经召集了一群朋友在附近搜寻，但他们的努力没有取得任何结果。吉尔多逼问埃利安娜那天早上埃莉萨最后已知的行踪的准确细节。埃利安娜最终承认她并没有完全说实话。两个女孩从来没打算一起去参加弥撒。这只是个借口，好让埃莉萨去见一个朋友——21岁的牙科专业学生达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃。埃莉萨对这次会面很不情愿，因为她知道雷斯蒂沃对她有单方面的浪漫情愫，而且她觉得这个人挺古怪的。但雷斯蒂沃一直坚持不懈，因为他想
give her a gift for passing her recent exams. Elisa agreed on account of feeling sorry for him. Although he came from a prominent family, with his father serving as director of the local branch of the National Library, Restivo was a loner with few friends. He was often teased for his effeminate voice and mannerisms, and he lacked people's girls. He frequently behaved strangely towards girls, bragging that he could convince women to sleep with him for the Philip Morris cigarettes he constantly had in his possession. Restivo and Elisa had arranged to meet inside the church at 11.30 am, just as mass was finishing. Eliana waited outside, where she ran into another of the girl's friends, Angelica. Neither girl saw Elisa leave the church.
送她一件礼物，庆祝她最近考试通过。出于同情，埃莉萨答应了。尽管雷斯蒂沃出身显赫家庭，他的父亲担任国家图书馆当地分馆的馆长，但他是个孤僻的人，朋友很少。他经常因为女性化的嗓音和举止而受到嘲笑，而且缺乏人际交往能力。他对女孩的行为常常很古怪，吹嘘自己能说服女性跟他上床，代价是他随身携带的菲利普·莫里斯香烟。雷斯蒂沃和埃莉萨原本约定在上午11点30分弥撒快结束时在教堂内部见面。埃利安娜在外面等候，并在那里遇到了女孩们的另一个朋友安杰利卡。两个女孩都没有看到埃莉萨离开教堂。
Gildor recalled he had overheard his younger sister talking to Restivo on the phone the previous evening. Gildor didn't like Restivo, he found him odd and was suspicious of his interest in Elisa. The siblings had run into him during a recent holiday, and the encounter had unnerved Elisa, who suspected Restivo may have followed her there. Despite her obvious discomfort, she had reassured her protective older brother that Restivo meant no harm. Gildor wasn't convinced, unable to shake the feeling that there was something shady about Restivo. As Restivo was the last person believed to have been with Elisa, Gildor called his family house demanding answers. Restivo told him their meeting had only lasted 15 minutes,
吉尔多回忆说，前一天晚上他无意中听到妹妹在电话里和雷斯蒂沃说话。吉尔多不喜欢雷斯蒂沃，他觉得这个人很古怪，并对雷斯蒂沃对埃莉萨的兴趣感到怀疑。兄妹俩曾在最近的一次假期中偶遇过他，那次偶遇让埃莉萨感到不安，她怀疑雷斯蒂沃可能一路尾随她到了那里。尽管感到明显的不适，她还是安慰她那具有保护欲的哥哥，说雷斯蒂沃没有恶意。吉尔多并不买账，无法摆脱那种觉得雷斯蒂沃有些阴暗的感觉。由于雷斯蒂沃被认为是最后一个和埃莉萨在一起的人，吉尔多给他的家里打电话质问。雷斯蒂沃告诉他，他们的会面只持续了15分钟，
during which the pair sat by the altar and chatted. Elisa had seemed a little troubled, as she said she had been harassed by a man in town earlier that morning. Afterwards, she left the church and Restivo stayed behind to pray, which is the last time he saw her. As the hour passed by and there was still no sign of Elisa, her brother Luciano paid a visit to Restivo's family home to question him in person. Restivo hesitated to answer any questions and stuttered over his answers, appearing sweaty and agitated. Luciano observed he had a large plaster on the back of his left hand and asked what happened. Restivo explained he had tripped over in a building site and cut his hand, requiring a visit to the hospital. He insisted he knew
期间两人坐在圣坛旁聊天。埃莉萨看起来有点烦恼，因为她说那天早上在镇上曾遭到一个男人的骚扰。之后，她离开了教堂，而雷斯蒂沃留下来祈祷，那是他最后一次见到她。随着时间的流逝依然不见埃莉萨的踪影，她的哥哥卢西亚诺拜访了雷斯蒂沃的家，当面盘问他。雷斯蒂沃回答问题时犹豫不决，结结巴巴，显得满头大汗且情绪激动。卢西亚诺注意到他左手手背上有一大块膏药，便问发生了什么事。雷斯蒂沃解释说他在一个建筑工地绊倒并割伤了手，为此去过医院。他坚称自己
nothing about Elisa's whereabouts or where she went after leaving the church. Luciano left the Restivo residence and returned a few hours later with Gildor in tow. The clapped brothers were greeted at the door by Restivo's parents, who advised the siblings that their son had left for the 150-kilometer westerly journey to Naples to undertake his dentistry exams the next day. Overwhelmed with concern, the claps attended the local police station to report Elisa is missing. Officers on duty recorded the details, but advised the panicked family not to worry, reassuring them Elisa was a teenager and was most likely just out with friends. This was frustrating for the claps, who knew Elisa was an obedient and well behaved girl,
对埃莉萨的下落或她离开教堂后的去向一无所知。卢西亚诺离开雷斯蒂沃的住所，几小时后带着吉尔多折返。克拉普斯兄弟在门口受到了雷斯蒂沃父母的迎接，老两口告知兄妹俩，他们的儿子已经启程前往150公里以西的那不勒斯，准备参加第二天进行的牙科考试。满心焦虑的克拉普斯一家前往当地警察局报案称埃莉萨失踪。值班警官记录了细节，但劝告恐慌的家人不必担心，安慰他们说埃莉萨是个青少年，很可能只是和朋友们出去了。这让克拉普斯一家感到沮丧，因为他们知道埃莉萨是一个听话且乖巧的女孩，
who would never stay out without letting someone in her family know first. They urged the police to question Danilo Restivo, but their request was dismissed, with the officers suggesting the claps return home and wait for Elisa to show up instead. Unsure of what else to do, Gildor returned to the church of the Holy Trinity, this time finding the door was locked. He tracked someone down who had access to the key and they led him inside to search the area once again. Gildor scoured the empty pews and as he approached the altar, noticed the wooden door that gave access to the upper levels of the church was locked. Gildor asked to gain entry, but was informed that the only person who had a key to the door was
绝不会在不先通知家人的情况下在外面过夜。他们敦促警方盘问达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃，但请求被驳回，警官建议克拉普斯一家回家等待埃莉萨出现。吉尔多不知还能做些什么，便回到了圣三一教堂，这次发现门锁着。他找到一个有钥匙的人，对方带他进门再次搜查了该区域。吉尔多搜寻了空荡荡的长椅，当他走近圣坛时，注意到通往教堂上层的木门被锁上了。吉尔多要求进入，但被告知唯一拥有这扇门钥匙的人是
the priest, Father Dominico Sabia, known as Don Mimmi. Don Mimmi had left after mass that afternoon to attend the spa retreat for the next few days. That night, Gildor, Luciano and their friends stayed up until the early hours, combing the streets on foot and in cars, desperately searching for any sign of Elisa. Meanwhile, Antonio and Filomena sat by the phone, desperately willing their daughter to contact them. The phone rang off the hook with calls from concerned friends, relatives, townspeople and journalists, but there was no word from Elisa. Upon answering the phone on several occasions, the claps were simply met with a long, eerie silence. The following day, Monday, September 13, police began taking Elisa's disappearance more seriously,
神父多米尼科·萨比亚，人称多米尼米神父。多米尼米神父那天下午弥撒结束后就离开去温泉度假村呆几天了。那天晚上，吉尔多、卢西亚诺和他们的朋友们熬夜到凌晨，步行和开车梳理着街道，绝望地寻找埃莉萨的任何踪迹。与此同时，安东尼奥和菲洛梅娜守在电话旁，绝望地祈愿女儿能联系他们。电话响个不停，打来电话的全是关切的朋友、亲戚、镇民和记者，但没有一丝埃莉萨的消息。克拉普斯一家好几次接起电话，听到的却只有漫长而诡异的沉默。第二天，即9月13日星期一，警方开始更加严肃地对待埃莉萨的失踪，
but remained convinced she would likely show up soon. Elisa's family and friends took to the streets of Pazanza, asking passers-by if they had seen the dark-haired, dark-eyed, 16-year-old. Lost police inquired with local hospitals as to whether anyone matching Elisa's description had been admitted. The claps printed large posters of Elisa's smiling face along with pleas for information and distributed them across the city, as her disappearance began gaining media attention on local radio and television stations. As the search intensified, the claps began receiving all kinds of tip-offs from members of the public, with alleged sightings coming in from all over Italy. Numerous witnesses recalled seeing someone who matched Elisa's description in a white Fiat
但仍然坚信她很快就会出现。埃莉萨的家人和朋友走上波坦察的街头，询问路人是否见过这个黑发黑眼、16岁的女孩。失踪案警察向当地医院查询是否有人符合埃莉萨的特征入院。克拉普斯一家印制了埃莉萨微笑着的大幅海报以及寻人呼吁，并在全城散发，同时她的失踪开始在当地广播和电视台获得媒体关注。随着搜寻的加剧，克拉普斯一家开始收到来自公众的各种线索，声称在意大利各地都看到了目击报告。许多目击者回忆说，曾在一辆白色的菲亚特
Uno Vigil, whilst anonymous callers claimed they had Elisa with them, unharmed. Police dismissed the majority of the dubious tip-offs, as none aligned with the times or location Elisa was last seen. A plausible report from Elisa's friend D'Angelica, who had run into Eliana outside the church the previous day, claimed another of Elisa's admirers had been hanging around the city centre that day. 20-year-old Ares Gagar. Gagar and his family had recently moved to Potenza from their home country of Albania, meeting the girls at a church camp. The claps contacted Gagar to see if he had any information about Elisa's whereabouts, but he denied being anywhere near the church on the day of her disappearance and insisted he hadn't seen her. That afternoon, as Danilo Restivo
乌诺轿车里看到过符合埃莉萨特征的人，而匿名来电者则声称埃莉萨和他们在一起，毫发无伤。警方驳回了大多数可疑的线索，因为没有一条与埃莉萨最后一次被看到的时间或地点相吻合。来自埃莉萨的朋友安杰利卡的一个可信报告称，她前一天在教堂外遇到了埃莉萨，并声称埃莉萨的另一个崇拜者那天一直在市中心闲逛。20岁的阿雷斯·加加尔。加加尔和他的家人最近从他们的祖国阿尔巴尼亚搬到了波坦察，在一次教堂夏令营中认识了这些女孩。克拉普斯一家联系了加加尔，看他是否有关于埃莉萨下落的任何信息，但他否认在埃莉萨失踪当天去过教堂附近，并坚称自己没有见过她。那天下午，随着达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃
returned from his dentistry exams, police brought him in for formal questioning. He told them Elisa was unhappy at home and had plans to run away to Naples, a densely populated city in southern Italy with a reputation for crime and mafia activity. Restivo claimed he had attempted to talk Elisa out of this plan, warning her of the dangers a young girl faced out on the streets of the gritty and harsh city. He maintained his original story that she had left the church following their brief conversation and that he had stayed behind to pray. Although he made no mention of the present he allegedly wanted to give Elisa for completing her exams, instead stating the purpose of their meeting was to ask her advice about another girl he was interested in dating
从牙科考试中归来，警方将他带走进行正式审讯。他告诉警方，埃莉萨在家里过得不开心，并有计划私奔去那不勒斯——那是意大利南部一个人口稠密、以犯罪和黑手党活动闻名的城市。雷斯蒂沃声称他曾试图劝说埃莉萨放弃这个计划，警告她一个年轻女孩在这个粗粝严酷的城市街头会面临危险。他坚持他最初的说法，即她在他们简短的谈话后离开了教堂，而他留下来祈祷。尽管他闭口不提据称要送给埃莉萨作为考试通过礼物的物品，却改口称他们会面的目的是向她征求关于另一个他想追求的女孩的建议，
named Paola. Afterwards, he walked home, traversing through a building site which he had visited with Paola a few days earlier, where he fell and cut his hand. The cut was bleeding so he wrapped his hand in his jacket. When Restivo returned home and showed the injury to his sister, she insisted he go to the hospital to have it cleaned up, accompanying him there at around 1pm. He was seen by a doctor shortly after, receiving a single stitch for the 1cm long laceration. Investigators noted Restivo seemed unusually precise in his answers which aroused their suspicion. They were also dubious of his claims that Elisa had an unhappy home life as there was nothing to support this theory, with friends attesting to the closeness of her loving family.
那个女孩名叫保拉。之后，他步行回家，穿过一个几天前他曾和保拉一起参观过的建筑工地，在那里他摔倒并割伤了手。伤口在流血，所以他用夹克把手包了起来。当雷斯蒂沃回到家并将伤势展示给姐姐时，姐姐坚持要他去医院清洗伤口，并在下午1点左右陪他去了医院。不久后他被一位医生接诊，那条1厘米长的裂口被缝合了一针。调查人员注意到雷斯蒂沃的回答异常精确，这引起了他们的怀疑。他们也对雷斯蒂沃关于埃莉萨家庭生活不愉快的说法表示怀疑，因为没有任何证据支持这一理论，朋友们证明她的家庭充满爱且关系紧密。
Police requested Restivo lead them to the building site where he sustained his hand injury to re-enact his movements. He complied and at the site described falling head first down a full flight of escalators that were currently under construction. This seemed curious to police as Restivo wore glasses and they had miraculously remained intact during this lengthy fall. It also didn't make sense that the only injury sustained after such a tumble was just the small cut on his hand. They visited Restivo's residence and requested his parents provide them with the blood-stained clothing their son had been wearing at the time of his fall. His powerful and well-connected father Mauricio Restivo insisted on seeing a search warrant first. As no such warrant had been obtained,
警方要求雷斯蒂沃带他们去他手臂受伤的建筑工地以重现他的动作。他照办了，并在现场描述说自己头朝下摔下了一整段正在施工中的自动扶梯。这让警方感到好奇，因为雷斯蒂沃戴着眼镜，而它们在经历如此漫长的摔落时竟然奇迹般地完好无损。经历这样一场跌落后，唯一的伤势居然只是手上那个小伤口，这也说不通。他们走访了雷斯蒂沃的住所，并要求其父母交出儿子摔倒时穿着的沾血衣物。他那权势显赫、背景深厚的父亲毛里齐奥·雷斯蒂沃坚持要求先看搜查令。由于并未获得此类搜查令，
police left the property empty-handed. Convinced that Nilo Restivo was hiding something, police ran a search on his name and discovered he had been involved in a violent attack in the past. In 1989, the then 14-year-old was playing a game of cowboys and Indians with two adolescent boys when he told them he would take them to his secret hideout. He proceeded to tie their hands up, blindfold them and lock them up before inflicting the younger of the two with a small knife wound to his neck. The cut required stitches and the families of the two boys pressed charges which were later dropped when the Restivo family settled the incident outside of court with a small financial sum. It wasn't the only criminal behaviour Restivo had
警方空手离开了该物业。确信尼洛·雷斯蒂沃在隐瞒什么的警方对他的名字进行了搜索，发现他过去曾卷入过一起暴力袭击事件。1989年，当时14岁的他正和两个未成年男孩玩牛仔和印第安人的游戏，当时他告诉他们会带他们去他的秘密藏身处。他接着把他们的手绑起来、蒙上眼睛并锁了起来，然后用小刀刺伤了两人中较小者的颈部。这道伤口需要缝针，两个男孩的家属提出了指控，但后来由于雷斯蒂沃家族以一笔小额资金在庭外和解了该事件，指控被撤销。这并不是雷斯蒂沃表现出的唯一
exhibited. A few months earlier, he had been accused of harassing three female students who lived in an apartment complex directly across from his family's home. Over the course of several months, the women reported being subject to harrowing phone calls in which Restivo, under the guise of anonymity, attempted to scare them by describing the clothes they were currently wearing. He would play music into the phone from horror movie soundtracks and to the classical Beethoven song for release. He would also send pornographic drawings, twisted love letters and death threats, all written under false names. The early stages of the investigation into Elisa Clapp's disappearance continued to be
犯罪行为。几个月前，他曾被指控骚扰三名女学生，她们住在紧邻他家公寓楼的一栋公寓里。在几个月的时间里，这些女性报告说遭到了令人痛苦的电话骚扰，雷斯蒂沃在匿名伪装下，试图通过描述她们当时穿的衣服来吓唬她们。他会在电话里播放恐怖电影原声带中的音乐以及贝多芬的古典名曲《献给爱丽丝》。他还寄送色情画作、扭曲的情书和死亡威胁，全部用假名签署。对埃莉萨·克拉普斯失踪案的早期调查继续
marred by inaccurate, false and conflicting information. Sightings kept coming in from local residents who recalled seeing Elisa after her meeting with Restivo, but police were unable to determine whether witnesses were confused with the timings or were purposely providing misleading information to stall the investigation. One witness claimed to have seen Elisa being forced into a red vehicle by two men, but she later retracted her statement entirely. Investigators circulated details of the case to other police stations throughout the country, and although wary of Restivo's claims, they alerted officials in Naples to the possibility the missing teenager could have travelled there. With so little viable information coming through
受到不准确、虚假和矛盾信息的损害。当地居民不断传来目击报告，回忆说在埃莉萨与雷斯蒂沃会面后看到了她，但警方无法确定目击者是搞混了时间，还是故意提供误导性信息来阻碍调查。一名目击者声称看到埃莉萨被两名男子强行塞进一辆红色汽车，但她后来完全收回了自己的供词。调查人员将案件详情通报给全国其他警察局，尽管对雷斯蒂沃的说法保持警惕，但他们还是提醒那不勒斯官员注意失踪少女可能已经前往那里的可能性。由于流传的有效信息太少，
and no proof that a crime had occurred, investigators were starting to believe Elisa had simply run away from home and didn't want to be found. This possibility was vehemently disputed by the claps as none of her clothes or belongings were missing. A member of her family said, she has not gone anywhere on her own free will. Wherever she is, she's been taken by force. We shall not rest until we have her home. On September 22, 10 days since Elisa was last seen, her Albanian friend Ares Gagar was brought in for questioning about the witness sightings that placed him near the Church of the Holy Trinity on the day of the team's disappearance. Gagar denied being in the area that day, saying he never left
且没有证据表明发生了犯罪，调查人员开始相信埃莉萨只是离家出走，不想被找到。这种可能性遭到克拉普斯一家的强烈反驳，因为她的衣服和随身物品一件都没有少。她的一位家属说：“她绝不是出于自愿离开任何地方的。无论她在哪里，她都是被强行带走的。在我们把她接回家之前，我们绝不会罢休。”9月22日，距离埃莉萨最后一次露面已过去10天，她的阿尔巴尼亚朋友阿雷斯·加加尔被带去接受盘问，起因是目击证人的证词将他置于少女失踪当天的圣三一教堂附近。加加尔否认那天在那个地区，称他从未离开过
his neighbourhood and gave police the names of friends who could vouch for his whereabouts. When police made contact with these friends, they disputed Gagar's story, confirming that he was in fact in the city centre near the Church that day. Gagar also drove a white Fiat Uno, the same car several witnesses had described seeing Elisa in on the day of her disappearance. Suspicions that Gagar could be involved were heightened when Elisa's diary was recovered and analysed, revealing that several pages had been ripped out. Scientists were able to reconstruct segments of the torn pages and discovered that some of the words had been written in Albanian. Gagar was questioned again in October and early December with his story changing each time.
他的社区，并向警方提供了可以为他的行踪作证的朋友的名字。当警方联系这些朋友时，他们反驳了加加尔的说法，证实他那天确实在教堂附近的市中心。加加尔还驾驶一辆白色的菲亚特乌诺，这正是几位目击者描述在失踪当天看到埃莉萨乘坐的同一辆车。当埃莉萨的日记被找到并经过分析，显示有几页被撕掉时，加加尔可能涉案的怀疑加剧了。科学家们得以重构被撕毁页面的部分内容，并发现其中一些词是用阿尔巴尼亚语写的。加加尔在10月和12月初再次接受盘问，他的说法每次都在变。
At one point, he claimed Danilo Restivo had approached him and told him to deny to the police that the two knew one another. A witness who claimed to have seen Elisa in the white Fiat Uno was shown a photograph of Gagar and accepted he shared some physical similarities to the vehicle's driver. On December 22, Ares Gagar was placed under arrest for providing false statements and held in custody pending trial. Meanwhile, investigators received a tip-off from a concerned citizen urging them to keep looking into Danilo Restivo, claiming he had exhibited some other disturbing behaviour. According to the caller, Restivo had a reputation around town for cutting the hair of unsuspecting young women on public transport. Whilst it was true that police had
有一刻，他声称达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃曾接近他，并告诉他向警方否认两人相识。一名声称在白色菲亚特乌诺中看到过埃莉萨的目击者被出示了一张加加尔的照片，并承认他在体貌特征上与这辆车的司机有一些相似之处。12月22日，阿雷斯·加加尔因提供虚假供述而被捕，并在候审期间被拘留。与此同时，调查人员接到了一名热心市民的线索，敦促他们继续调查达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃，声称他曾表现出其他一些令人不安的行为。据来电者称，雷斯蒂沃在镇上有一个名声，喜欢在公共交通上剪掉毫无戒心的年轻女性的头发。虽然警察
received multiple reports of such incidents in the past, there was no evidence to suggest Restivo was the perpetrator of these bizarre acts. In December, an anonymous phone call was placed to the police by a female who claimed to have spotted Elisa in Italy's capital city of Rome, 350km northwest from Patenza. Elisa was allegedly sighted being beaten and forced into a white Fiat Uno. At the end of the call, the voice pleaded, help her and help me. A recording of the call was sent for expert analysis and the results were surprising. The female caller was identified to be Elisa's friend, Eliana DeSillis. Investigators had been suspicious of Eliana since the initial stages of the investigation,
过去确实收到过多次此类事件的报告，但没有证据表明雷斯蒂沃是这些怪异行为的肇事者。12月，一名女性打匿名电话给警方，声称在意大利首都罗马——距离波坦察西北350公里处——发现了埃莉萨。据称埃莉萨被目击遭到殴打并被强行推入一辆白色的菲亚特乌诺。电话快结束时，那个声音恳求道：“救救她，也救救我。”这通电话的录音被送去进行专家分析，结果令人惊外。女来电者被识别出是埃莉萨的朋友埃利安娜·德西利斯。调查人员从调查的最初阶段就对埃利安娜产生过怀疑，
as there were elements of her story that didn't quite add up, and she changed her version of events often. One witness had reported seeing Elisa riding passenger on Eliana's moped near the claps home at approximately 12.30pm on the day she went missing, and even described the very clothing the two teenagers had been wearing. Eliana strongly denied this sighting, insisting she hadn't taken her moped out that day. In addition, it was her boyfriend's mother who had tipped police off to Danilo Restivo's alleged disturbing haircutting habits. Investigators were now considering the possibility the claim was a ploy to deflect attention from Eliana, just like the false sighting of Elisa in Rome. If the witness sighting of Elisa riding
因为她故事中的某些元素并不完全吻合，而且她经常改变事件的版本。一名目击者曾报告称，在埃莉萨失踪当天的下午12点30分左右，看到埃莉萨坐在埃利安娜的轻便摩托车后座上，甚至描述了两个少女当时穿的衣服。埃莉萨坚决否认了这次目击，坚称她那天没有把轻便摩托车开出去。此外，正是她男友的母亲向警方透露了达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃据称令人不安的剪发癖好。调查人员现在正在考虑这样一种可能性：这一说法只是为了转移对埃利安娜的注意力，就像罗马发现埃莉萨的虚假目击一样。如果目击者看到埃莉萨坐在
passenger on Eliana's moped at approximately 12.30pm was correct, this meant Eliana was with Elisa after her meeting with Restivo at the church. For the misleading phone call, Eliana was charged with providing false information and scheduled to appear in court the following year, with police confirming they weren't ruling her out of the investigation. The case languished for months, with the claps family convinced Elisa was likely no longer alive, and that Danilo Restivo was responsible for her death. But to their frustration, the police still hadn't ruled out the possibility she had run away from home. It hadn't taken long for the claps to suspect there were higher powers at play protecting the reputation of their daughter's killer. Given Maurizio Restivo was
埃利安娜的轻便摩托车后座上的说法在下午12点30分左右是正确的，这意味着埃莉萨在教堂与雷斯蒂沃会面后曾与埃利安娜在一起。由于这个误导性的电话，埃利安娜被控提供虚假信息，并定于第二年出庭受审，警方证实他们并未将她排除在调查之外。案件沉寂了数月，克拉普斯一家确信埃莉萨很可能已经不在人世，而达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃对她的死负有责任。但令他们沮丧的是，警方仍未排除她离家出走的可能性。克拉普斯一家很快就怀疑有更高层的权力在幕后操纵，以保护女儿凶手的声誉。鉴于毛里齐奥·雷斯蒂沃是
a prominent man in Potenza, with strong ties to the social elite and church officials, they were convinced he had used his position of power to protect his son, and ultimately, his family's reputation. In addition, they felt the church of the Holy Trinity Priest, Father Don Mimmi, was purposely obstructing the investigation and sighting with the Restivo family. He had denied the claps access to search the upper levels of the church, and had refused to let them place a box in the church where people with information could leave anonymous notes, despite all other churches in Potenza warmly allowing this service. Don Mimmi had also denied knowing Danilo Restivo, which was quickly proven to be a lie, when a photograph surfaced of the two standing
作为波坦察的一位显赫人物，他与社会精英和教会官员关系密切。人们确信他利用权力保护了自己的儿子，最终也维护了家族的声誉。此外，他们认为圣三一教堂的神父唐·米米（Don Mimmi）故意阻挠调查，并偏袒雷斯蒂沃家族。尽管波坦察的其他所有教堂都热情地允许设立这样一个服务点，允许知情者匿名留言，但唐·米米却拒绝让克拉普一家进入教堂搜查高层区域，也拒绝在教堂放置一个收集匿名线索的箱子。唐·米米还曾否认认识达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃，但一张两人站在
side by side in celebration at Restivo's 18th birthday party. Elisa's family spoke of their pain in an article with Southern Italian newspaper La Gazetta della Mesa Giorno, in which Filomena claps voiced her disappointment with the police. She blamed the corrupt systems, politics, and churches of the Basilicata region for the lack of action in helping find her daughter, saying, I am a simple person and I ask for simple answers, but there's nothing simple about the way this region is run. The grieving mother said she just wanted closure and a final resting place for her daughter. Somewhere she could go to place flowers and sit beside her.
雷斯蒂沃18岁生日派对上并肩庆祝的照片浮出水面后，这个谎言很快被戳穿。埃利萨的家人在意大利南部报纸《晨报》（La Gazetta della Mesa Giorno）的一篇报道中倾诉了他们的痛苦，菲洛梅娜·克拉普在文中表达了她对警方的失望。她将寻找女儿毫无进展归咎于巴斯利卡塔地区腐败的体制、政治和教会，并说道：“我是一个简单的人，我只想要简单的答案，但这个地区的运作方式一点也不简单。”这位悲痛的母亲表示，她只想给女儿一个交代和最后的安息之地。一个她可以去献花并陪伴左右的地方。
Quote, I miss her sitting at the table. I miss her hugs. She was always so happy, always so loving. I often talk with her. We have conversations in my head as if she's in the room with me. In fact, she is here. I know it. Which makes me sad, because it means she can only be here in spirit and will never walk through the door again. I am lost without her. She is my first and last thought every day. A hopeful lead came through when police received a tip-off that someone matching Elisa's description who spoke Italian had been spotted across the Adriatic Sea in Albania. The lead gained credibility when the witness claimed that the month Elisa went missing, sex traffickers returned to Albania from Italy in possession
“引文：我怀念她坐在桌旁的樣子。我怀念她的拥抱。她总是那么快乐，总是那么充满爱意。我经常和她说话。我们在我的脑海里交谈，就像她和我待在同一个房间里一样。事实上，她就在这里。我知道这一点。这让我很难过，因为这意味着她只能以灵魂的形式存在，再也不会走进这扇门了。没有她，我迷失了方向。她是我每天的第一个和最后一个念头。”当警方接到一条线索称，在亚得里亚海对岸的阿尔巴尼亚发现了一个外貌与埃利萨相似、会说意大利语的人时，一个充满希望的线索出现了。当目击者声称在埃利萨失踪的那个月，人口贩子带着
of a dark-haired teenage girl. Investigators and news crews travelled to the Balkan country in search of her, but the whole story turned out to be a ruse, designed to gain money and publicity for the false witness. By June 1994, the investigation into Elisa's disappearance had hit a dead end. The case was reviewed, and an eight-page interim report was prepared by the head of the police force Luigi Grimaldi, concluding that Elisa was a well-behaved teenager who would never put her mother through the torment of running away from home. Given her family wasn't well off, the possibility that she had been kidnapped for ransom was also excluded. As was the theory she had been abducted and forced into sex slavery, as it was unlikely such gangs would operate in
一个黑发少女从意大利返回阿尔巴尼亚时，这条线索的可信度增加了。调查人员和新闻摄制组前往这个巴尔干国家寻找她，但整个故事结果证明是一场骗局，旨在为假目击者骗取金钱和知名度。到1994年6月，对埃利萨失踪案的调查陷入了死胡同。案件经过了重新审查，警察局长路易吉·格里马尔迪（Luigi Grimaldi）撰写了一份八页的中期报告，得出结论认为埃利萨是一个品行端正的青少年，绝不会让母亲经受离家出走的折磨。鉴于她家境并不富裕，她为勒索而被绑架的可能性也被排除在外。同样被排除的还有她被绑架并被迫沦为性奴的说法，因为这种团伙不大可能在周日光天化日之下、在人多繁忙的教堂附近作案。
broad daylight on a Sunday in the vicinity of a busy church. Grimaldi's report ultimately concluded that Elisa claps had likely been murdered by someone she knew and her body was hidden somewhere in Potenza. He spotlighted Danilo Restivo and Ares Gega as the main suspects, with Restivo's suspicious hand injury and the fact he was the last one to see Elisa alive, making him the most likely perpetrator. He recommended Danilo Restivo be placed under arrest, but the request was denied by the magistrate leading the investigation. In early September 1994, as the one-year anniversary of Elisa's disappearance approached, the residents of Potenza planned a procession in her honor. Then on September 10, two days before it was scheduled to take place, Danilo Restivo was once
格里马尔迪的报告最终得出结论：埃利萨·克拉普很可能是被她认识的人谋杀的，她的尸体被藏在波坦察的某个地方。他指出达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃和阿雷斯·格加（Ares Gega）是主要嫌疑人，雷斯蒂沃可疑的手部伤势以及他是最后一个看到活着的埃利萨这一事实，使他成为最可能的作案者。他建议将达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃逮捕，但领导调查的治安法官拒绝了这一请求。1994年9月初，随着埃利萨失踪一周年纪念日的临近，波坦察的居民计划为她举行一场游行。接着在9月10日，即游行计划举行的两天前，达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃再次
again questioned by investigators determined to catch out the inconsistencies in his stories. They put it to him that the fall he had described at the building site was inconsistent with the injuries he had sustained, asking him if there was any other information he wanted to come clean with. Restivo maintained he was being truthful and had nothing to hide, but the investigators were unconvinced and placed him under arrest for deliberately providing false information. He was assigned to the same cell as Ares Gega, which had been fitted with a covert listening device in the hopes the two suspects would discuss Elisa's disappearance and divulge information that could be of use to the investigation. Following the arrest, the heat was temporarily
遭到决心找出其供词中矛盾之处的调查人员的讯问。他们向他指出，他在建筑工地描述的那次摔倒与他受到的伤并不相符，并问他是否还有其他想坦白的隐情。雷斯蒂沃坚称自己说的是实话，没有什么可隐瞒的，但调查人员并不相信，并以故意提供虚假信息为由将他逮捕。他被分配到与阿雷斯·格加同一间牢房，该牢房安装了秘密窃听装置，希望这两个嫌疑人会讨论埃利萨的失踪并泄露对调查有用的大量信息。逮捕发生后，随着
taken off for Restivo when Ares Gega's lawyer went straight to the media with the new information that Elisa had once again been cited in Albania, this time in a remote village. Many viewed it as odd that the lawyer would actively draw attention back to his client's home country, and the announcement did nothing but heighten suspicions that Gega was involved in Elisa's disappearance. Law enforcement followed up the claims as television crews rushed to the Albanian village to interview local residents, but the supposed sightings of Elisa turned out to be a lookalike. Furthermore, police attempts to record Restivo and Gega providing incriminating information were unsuccessful. During their time together in jail, the two men never discussed
阿雷斯·格加的律师直接向媒体透露了埃利萨再次在阿尔巴尼亚（这次是在一个偏远村庄）被目击的新信息，雷斯蒂沃身上的压力暂时得到了缓解。许多人认为，律师主动将注意力重新吸引到他当事人的祖国这一举动十分怪异，这一声明除了加剧格加参与埃利萨失踪案的嫌疑外，没有起到任何作用。执法部门跟进调查了这些说法，电视摄制组也蜂拥至阿尔巴尼亚的村庄采访当地居民，但所谓的埃利萨目击事件结果证明只是一个相貌相似的人。此外，警方试图录下雷斯蒂沃和格加提供罪证信息的尝试也失败了。在他们一起在监狱服刑期间，这两个男人从未讨论过
Elisa or the case at all. In January 1995, Danilo Restivo appeared in the Patanza Criminal Court to face the perjury charges against him. Tension was palpable between the claps and to Restivo families, but the accused presented as calm and confident, as his lawyer reminded the court his client was simply on trial for deliberately providing false information and not for his involvement with Elisa claps disappearance. The trial was lengthy, hindered by interruptions and delays common in Italy's legal system. Various witnesses took the stand, including the doctor who had treated the wound on Restivo's hand. The doctor stated it was unlikely Restivo's injury had been caused by a fall at the building site, and more likely it was caused by a sharp
埃利萨或此案。1995年1月，达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃出庭帕坦察刑事法院，面对针对他的伪证罪指控。克拉普家族和雷斯蒂沃家族之间的紧张气氛显而易见，但被告表现得冷静而自信，因为他的律师提醒法庭，他的当事人仅仅是因为故意提供虚假信息而受审，而不是因为他参与了埃利萨·克拉普的失踪案。审判历时漫长，受到了意大利法律体系中常见的干扰和拖延的阻碍。多位证人出庭作证，其中包括治疗雷斯蒂沃手部伤口的医生。这位医生表示，雷斯蒂沃的伤势不太可能是由建筑工地的跌落造成的，而更有可能是由锋利的
cutting object. Paola, the young woman Restivo claimed to have visited the building site with in the days before his injury, testified that she had never done any such thing. She told the court Restivo had once told her he had the potential to harm others when he was provoked and that he knew all the local churches inside out. At the same time his perjury trial was taking place, Restivo also faced court for separate charges relating to the three female students he had been harassing via phone and mail. For this crime he faced punishment of up to 18 days in prison, but was issued with a fine of 450,000 lira instead, the equivalent to around $450 in today's currency. In early March 1995, Danilo Restivo was found guilty of deliberately
切割物体造成的。雷斯蒂沃声称在受伤前几天曾同去过建筑工地的年轻女子保拉（Paola）出庭作证，称她从未做过任何此类事情。她告诉法庭，雷斯蒂沃曾对她说过，他在被激怒时有伤害他人的潜质，并且他对当地所有的教堂都了如指掌。在他面临伪证审判的同时，雷斯蒂沃还因通过电话和信件骚扰三名女学生的独立指控而出庭受审。对于这一罪行，他面临最高18天的监禁处罚，但最终被处以45万里拉的罚款，相当于今天货币的大约450美元。1995年3月初，达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃被判犯有故意
providing false information and sentenced to 20 months in prison. Outside court, Judo Klaps told reporters he couldn't understand how Restivo could be found guilty of being deceitful about what happened on the morning of Elisa's disappearance without being required to then provide the truth. Quote, Clearly, this isn't enough for my family. I don't believe that it's enough for the city of Potenza, for civil society. To us, a verdict of this sort is of no use. Ares Gagar and Eliana Desilis were both found not guilty for the perjury charges against them, with the judge concluding Eliana had not lied to deflect attention from herself, but out of fear that her own safety was in jeopardy.
提供虚假信息罪，判处20个月监禁。庭审结束后，朱多·克拉普（Judo Klaps）对记者表示，他无法理解雷斯蒂沃怎么会在埃利萨失踪那天早上的事情上被判欺瞒罪，却不需要随后说出真相。“引文：显然，这对我的家人来说还不够。我相信这对波坦察市、对公民社会来说也远远不够。对我们而言，这种判决毫无用处。”阿雷斯·加加（Ares Gagar）和埃利安娜·德西利斯（Eliana Desilis）针对他们的伪证指控均被判无罪，法官得出结论认为，埃利安娜撒谎并非为了转移对她自己的注意力，而是出于对自己人身安全受到威胁的恐惧。
Following the court proceedings, reports continued to come in from people who believed they had seen Elisa Klaps, with some witness sightings coming from as far away as Africa. By the time the two-year anniversary of her disappearance approached, every possible rumor had circulated through Potenza, including that Elisa had been caught up with the Sicilian Mafia, that she had been in a secret relationship with a priest, and that she had been sold into the and that she had been sold into the sex trade. The Klaps were inundated with people seeking money for information, wild claims from clairvoyants, and tip-offs that continuously led to painful dead ends. Danilo Restiva was released from prison after serving just 10 months of his
庭审结束后，声称见过埃利萨·克拉普的人的报告仍然络绎不绝，有些目击地点甚至远在非洲。随着她失踪两周年纪念日的临近，各种可能的谣言都在波坦察流传开来，包括埃利萨被西西里黑手党纠缠、她与神父有秘密恋情、以及她被卖入性交易市场。克拉普一家被索要金钱以换取线索的人、灵媒的荒谬说辞，以及不断导致痛苦死胡同的线索所淹没。达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃在服刑仅仅10个月后就从监狱释放了，
20-month sentence, and no further legal action was taken against him in relation to Elisa's disappearance. Police received more reports from young women who claimed to have had their hair mysteriously cut whilst travelling on public transport, several of whom worked with a sketch artist to create an image of the perpetrator. The resulting image bore a striking resemblance to Restiva. When shown a photograph of him, two women identified Restiva as the haircutter and agreed to participate in a police lineup, but changed their minds at the last minute after questioning the accuracy of their initial identification. Over time, the Elisa Klaps case started to fade from the headlines, although her family went to
20个月的刑期尚未期满，警方也没有对他采取进一步的法律行动。警方收到了更多年轻女性的报告，她们称自己在乘坐公共交通工具时头发被神秘地剪掉了，其中几人与素描艺术家合作绘制了犯罪嫌疑人的画像。最终的画像与雷斯蒂沃有着惊人的相似之处。当向两名女子展示他的照片时，她们认出雷斯蒂沃就是剪发者，并同意参加警方组织的辨认列队，但在最后关头，由于对他们最初辨认的准确性产生怀疑，她们改变了主意。随着时间的推移，埃利萨·克拉普案开始从头条新闻中淡出，尽管她的家人做出了
great efforts to keep it in the public consciousness. They appeared on television and radio shows at every opportunity, and plastered posters of Elisa's smiling face around the city. Her father Antonio became withdrawn, whilst her brothers and mother remained vigilant, looking into every single lead to ensure no stone went unturned. By 1998, five years had passed since Elisa's disappearance. Police declared the case was still open, but the investigation was no longer active. Media interests had dissipated, with the case only receiving rare mentions upon approaching anniversaries, whilst the leads, anonymous tip-offs and hoaxes had long since abated.
巨大的努力来维持公众的意识。他们抓住一切机会出现在电视和广播节目中，并在全市到处张贴埃利萨微笑的面孔的海报。她的父亲安东尼奥变得孤僻，而她的兄弟和母亲则保持警惕，调查每一个线索，确保不放过任何蛛丝马迹。到1998年，距离埃利萨失踪已经过去了五年。警方宣布该案仍然悬而未决，但调查已不再积极进行。媒体的兴趣已经消散，该案仅在临近周年纪念日时偶尔被提及，而线索、匿名举报和恶作剧早已平息。
As the internet emerged and grew in prominence, the Klaps created a website where people could find information about Elisa and the investigation. On April 23, 1999, an email was sent to the website attesting to be from Elisa herself. It claimed she had left Potenza at her own free will and was safe and well living in Brazil. She apologized for causing pain to her family and assured she had meant no harm, but had been unhappy and had to get away. She said she had no intention of coming home and had only decided to get in contact to put her family's minds at ease, explaining it would be the first and last time she would be in touch.
随着互联网的兴起和普及，克拉普一家建立了一个网站，供人们寻找关于埃莉萨及该调查的信息。1999年4月23日，该网站收到了一封电子邮件，声称发件人正是埃莉萨本人。邮件称她是自愿离开波坦察的，目前在巴西生活得安全而健康。她为给家人带来的痛苦道歉，并保证自己没有恶意，只是因为一直不开心而必须离开。她说自己无意回家，联系家人只是为了让他们的心头大石落地，并解释这将是她第一次也是最后一次与他们联系。
The email ended, this is hello and goodbye, forever. Desperate to believe it was real, Filomena clung to the hopes her daughter was living happily in another continent, but her sons weren't convinced, knowing their younger sister had left the house with no money and no passport. They employed the services of a private investigator who traced the IP address of the email, revealing it wasn't sent from Brazil at all, but from an internet café in Potenza. The family inquired with the café and obtained a list of all the registered users who had logged on to their computers that day. Logged in at the exact time the email had been sent was Danilo Restivo.
邮件的结尾是：这是问候，也是永别。菲洛梅娜渴望相信这是真的，她紧紧抓住女儿在另一个大洲幸福生活的希望，但她的儿子们并不相信，因为他们知道小妹妹离开家时既没有钱也没有护照。他们请了一名私家侦探，追查了这封邮件的IP地址，结果显示这封邮件根本不是从巴西发出的，而是来自波坦察的一家网吧。家人向该网吧进行了查询，并获得了当天登录其电脑的所有注册用户的名单。在邮件发送的精确时间登录的人正是达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃。
The claps immediately informed police and demanded Restivo be questioned over the email, convinced he had crafted the lie to encourage them to give up on the search. But they were bluntly told Elisa's case had now been shelved and there was nothing more investigators could do. In an interview with the journalist Tobias Jones for his book Blood on the Altar, Elisa's mother Filomena later said, Restivo is a wild beast that grew up in the forest. If I could, I would tear out his eyes. I could never forgive him, never. There's no saint that could forgive him. I can't leave Potenza. This is where Elisa grew up and this is where I'll die.
克拉普一家立即通知了警方，并要求就这封邮件对雷斯蒂沃进行讯问，他们确信他是捏造了这个谎言，以促使他们放弃搜寻。但警方直言不讳地告诉他们，埃莉萨的案子现在已经被搁置了，调查人员已经无能为力。埃莉萨的母亲菲洛梅娜后来在接受记者托比亚斯·琼斯为其新书《圣坛上的血》进行的采访时说：“雷斯蒂沃是一头在森林中长大的野兽。如果可以的话，我会挖出他的眼睛。我永远不会原谅他，永远不会。没有任何圣徒能够原谅他。我不能离开波坦察。这里是埃莉萨长大的地方，也是我将要死去的地方。”
And when I die, I want to close my eyes serenely and say, I did everything for Elisa. 1400 miles north from Potenza across the English Channel lies Bournemouth, a relatively quiet and peaceful seaside town located on the southern coast of Great Britain. With a population of approximately 190,000 residents, it is the largest town in southwest England's Dorset County. Given its access to the heritage-listed Jurassic Coast, a 155-kilometre long stretch of coastline, the area attracts around 7 million tourists per year. The 1992 foundation of the new Bournemouth University continues to attract students from all over the UK, Europe, and the rest of the world, accounting for a vast amount of the town's population.
“当我死去时，我想安详地闭上眼睛说，我为埃莉萨做了一切。”在波坦察以北1400英里、横越英吉利海峡的地方，坐落着伯恩茅斯，这是一个相对宁静祥和的海滨小镇，位于大不列颠岛南部海岸。这里人口约为19万，是英格兰西南部多塞特郡最大的城镇。凭借其通往被列入世界遗产名录的侏罗纪海岸（一条长达155公里的海岸线）的优势，该地区每年吸引约700万游客。1992年新伯恩茅斯大学的建立继续吸引着来自英国各地、欧洲以及世界各地的学生，他们占了该镇人口的很大一部分。
48-year-old Heather Barnett was born and raised in Dorset County, growing up in the small agricultural town of Sturminster, Newton, an area known for its livestock and dairy farms. As a young girl, down to Worth Heather was considered shy and quiet, but she came out of her shell as she grew up, singing in the church choir and performing in local pantomimes. Friends were drawn to her feisty and joyful personality, and she was popular within the town. Her father worked as an iron monger, and Heather often helped out at his shop to earn extra cash, before deciding to move to Bournemouth in her adulthood. Over the years, the tender and caring animal lover worked as a veterinary assistant, an au pair, and a waitress, before undertaking a
48岁的海瑟·巴内特在多塞特郡出生并长大，在斯特明斯特牛顿这个以畜牧业和奶牛场闻名的小农业镇度过了成长岁aqueous时光。作为年轻女孩时，海瑟被认为既害羞又安静，但随着年龄的增长，她变得开朗起来，在教堂唱诗班唱歌，并在当地的滑稽哑剧（pantomimes）中表演。朋友们都被她那好胜而快乐的性格所吸引，她在镇上很受欢迎。她的父亲是一名五金商，海瑟经常在父亲的店里帮忙以赚取零花钱，后来在成年后决定搬到伯恩茅斯。多年来这位温柔体贴的动物爱好者做过兽医助理、互惠生和女招待，之后在
curtain-making course at a local college. Heather soon fell in love with a man named David Marsh, and the two were married, giving birth to a son, Terry, in 1987, followed by a daughter, Caitlin, in 1991. Soon after the birth of their second child, the marriage hit rocky grounds, and Heather and David sought a divorce, leaving Heather to raise her two children predominantly as a single mother. The trio moved into a ground floor flat in a red brick building on Capstone Road, a quiet, working-class neighborhood situated off one of Bournemouth's main streets. Heather supported her family by putting her seamstress skills to use, sowing a range of items for clients around Dorset County, including curtains, tablecloths, cushions, and clothing.
当地一所大学修读了窗帘制作课程。海瑟很快和一个名叫大卫·马什的男人坠入爱河并结为夫妻，两人于1987年生下一个儿子特里，随后于1991年生下一个女儿凯特琳。第二个孩子出生后不久，婚姻便陷入了困境，海瑟和大卫寻求离婚，这使得海瑟主要作为一名单亲母亲抚养两个孩子。三人搬进了一栋红砖建筑的一楼公寓，位于卡普斯通路上，这是一个安静的工人阶级社区，坐落于伯恩茅斯某条主要街道旁。海瑟通过发挥她的裁缝技能来养家糊口，为多塞特郡各地的客户缝制各种物品，包括窗帘、桌布、靠垫和服装。
She worked from home, enabling her time to focus on raising her two children, who were her pride and joy. With limited income, Heather lived a frugal but happy life, often gushing to frugal, but happy life, often gushing to friends and neighbors about how proud she was of her kids and their performance at school. The morning of Tuesday, November 12, 2002, started like any other in Heather's household. Forever the early bird, she arose early, tending to the family's sick cat, before preparing breakfast for 14-year-old Terry and 11-year-old Caitlin. The Barnett children usually walked to school, but it was a gray, drizzly day, so Heather agreed to drive them, returning home from the drop-off shortly after 8.30 am.
她在家里工作，这使她有时间专注于抚养两个孩子，这是她的骄傲和快乐。由于收入有限，海瑟过着节俭但幸福的生活，她经常对朋友和邻居夸赞、但又幸福的生活，并常常向朋友和邻居滔滔不绝地讲述她为孩子们以及他们在学校的表现感到多么自豪。2002年11月12日星期二的早晨，和海瑟家里的任何一天一样开始了。作为一个永远的早起鸟，她很早就起床了，照顾家里生病的猫，然后为14岁的特里和11岁的凯特琳准备早餐。巴内特家的孩子们通常步行去学校，但那天是个阴冷下毛毛雨的日子，所以海瑟同意开车送他们，并在送完孩子后不久于早上8点30分左右回到家中。
She anticipated a normal day ahead, which typically consisted of a morning cup of tea, followed by making a few phone calls to clients, before sitting down to begin her sowing commissions. Hours later, at 3.30 pm, Terry and Caitlin arrived home from school, finding the front door unlocked, which they noted as odd, as their mother was known to be security conscious. They walked inside, throwing their backpacks down and calling out, hi mom. Heather usually met them at the door with a hug and a kiss, but strangely, she was nowhere to be seen. The kids knew their mother couldn't be too far away as her car was parked outside and the radio was playing. They looked around the small flat and noticed that her sowing machine had been
她预料前方会是平常的一天，通常包括早晨的一杯茶，接着给客户打几个电话，然后坐下来开始她的缝纫订单。几个小时后，即下午3点30分，特里和凯特琳放学回家，发现前门没有锁，他们觉得这很奇怪，因为他们的母亲以安全意识强而闻名。他们走进屋里，把背包扔在地上，喊着“嗨，妈妈”。海瑟通常会在门口用拥抱和亲吻迎接他们，但奇怪的是，她不见踪影。孩子们知道母亲不会走太远，因为她的车停在外面，收音机还在放着。他们环顾这间小公寓，注意到她的缝纫机已经被
knocked on its side and there were some other signs of disturbance. Caitlin timidly knocked on the bathroom door, calling out to ask if her mother was there. When there was no response, she slowly pushed the door open, finding Heather lying on the floor in a pool of blood. After seeing the terrifying scene for himself, Terry frantically called the police, telling them, my mom has been murdered, this is not a joke. The distressed siblings then raced out of the house and onto the street, waving their arms in a panic and desperately screaming for help. A couple who lived across the street were pulling up to their house when they noticed the two frantic children and quickly climbed out of their car to ask what was wrong.
撞得侧翻在地，并且还有其他一些遭到翻动的迹象。凯特琳怯生生地敲了敲浴室的门，大声询问母亲是否在里面。在没有任何回应的情况下，她缓缓推开门，发现海瑟倒在血泊中。在亲眼目睹了这可怕的一幕后，特里惊慌失措地报警，对他们说：“我妈妈被谋杀了，这不是开玩笑。”这对痛苦不堪的兄妹随后冲出家门跑向街上，绝望地挥舞着手臂，惊慌失措地大声呼救。住在街对面的一对夫妇正把车停在房子前，这时他们注意到了那两个惊慌失措的孩子，便迅速下车询问发生了什么事。
Due to the sheer scale of their distress, it was difficult to understand exactly what Caitlin and Terry were saying. When the couple realized what was going on, they directed the siblings into their flat to wait for the police to arrive, reassuring them that they were safe. The police soon arrived and cordoned off the entire street, declaring it a crime scene. They recorded the names and contact details of all the gathering onlookers to follow up for routine questioning in due course. Forensic pathologists were called to the site to determine the cause of Heather's death, who soon discovered the mother of two had sustained 10 forceful, fatal blows to the head with a heavy instrument thought to be a hammer,
由于他们极度的痛苦，很难听清凯特琳和特里到底在说些什么。当这对夫妇意识到发生了什么时，他们把这对兄妹领进自己的公寓等待警察到来，并安慰他们说他们是安全的。警察很快赶到并封锁了整条街道，将其宣布为犯罪现场。他们记录了所有聚集的旁观者的姓名和联系方式，以便在适当的时候进行例行盘问。法医病理学家被召集到现场以确定海瑟的死因，他们很快发现这位两个孩子的母亲头部受到了10次强有力且致命的打击，凶器被认为是锤子，
before having her throat slit. Her trousers were opened and her bra had been cut from the front, exposing her chest. Her breasts had been removed with a sharp object thought to be a 14cm long knife and carefully placed alongside her head. The lacerations were neat and precise, with the killer having been careful and controlled in their actions. A lack of blood from these injuries indicated the dismemberment had been inflicted post-mortem. The horrific mutilations implied the attack was sexually motivated, although no traces of semen were found. In both her hands, Heather was grasping several strands of human hair. Detective Superintendent Phil James quote,
随后她的喉咙被割断。她的裤子被敞开，胸罩从前面被剪断，露出了胸部。她的乳房被一把被认为是14厘米长的利器的尖锐物体切除，并整齐地摆放在她的头部旁边。这些伤口整齐精确，凶手在行动时小心翼翼且具有控制力。这些伤口缺乏出血表明肢解行为是在死后实施的。这些可怕的残缺暗示袭击具有性动机，尽管没有发现任何精液痕迹。海瑟的两只手紧紧抓着几缕人类头发。侦探总督察菲尔·詹姆斯引述说，
For Heather's two children to come home and find their mother this way is horrific. Not only have they been deprived of their mother, but the killer was so callous to allow them to see her this way. This is the sort of thing you'd only expect to see in the godfather. The temperature of Heather's body indicated she had been killed shortly after returning from dropping her children at school, with her time of death estimated as 9.30am. This was further supported by telephone records, which showed four incoming calls had come through to the Barnett flat between 10.56am and 4.15pm, all of which went unanswered. Scuff marks and overturned furniture revealed a desperate struggle in which Heather had tried
“对于海瑟的两个孩子来说，回到家发现母亲以这种方式遇害，实在是太可怕了。他们不仅失去了母亲，而且凶手竟如此冷酷无情，让他们看到了她这个样子。这就像你在《教父》里才能看到的场景。”海瑟的体温表明她在送完孩子上学回家后不久就被杀害了，其死亡时间估计为上午9点30分。这一点得到了电话记录的进一步支持，记录显示上午10点56分到下午4.15分之间有四个来电打进巴内特家的公寓，所有来电均无人接听。擦痕和被打翻的家具显示了一场绝望的挣扎，海瑟曾试图
to run for her life. Blood spatter found on the door near an upturned stool in Heather's sewing room marked the location where she had been violently struck. The blood stains also indicated she had sustained the head injuries whilst close to the floor, as though she had already been knocked to the ground before being hit from behind. Further blood patterns showed the perpetrator had then dragged her unconscious body to the bathroom, where they inflicted the knife wounds. Luminol tests identified trace elements of bloody footprints made from a size 9-11 Nike brand men's sneaker. The distinctive prints started in the bathroom, then led back into the sewing room and stopped by the time they reached the front hallway.
为生命而奔逃。在海瑟缝纫室一个翻倒的凳子附近的门上发现的血迹标志着她遭到暴力袭击的地点。血迹还表明她在靠近地面时头部受了伤，就好像她已经被击倒在地，然后才遭到从背后的打击。进一步的血迹模式显示，行凶者随后将她失去知觉的身体拖到浴室，并在那里施加了刀伤。鲁米诺测试识别出了由9到11码耐克（Nike）品牌男士运动鞋造成的血腥足迹的痕迹。这些独特的足迹从浴室开始，然后引导回缝纫室，并在到达前厅时停止。
It was suspected the killer had likely swapped their blood-soaked shoes for a cleaner pair they had brought with them before exiting the flat. Investigators conducted a thorough search of the crime scene and declared nothing had been stolen, ruling out the possibility the attack was motivated by theft. In addition, Heather's front door keys were sitting in the internal lock and there were no signs of forced entry, suggesting she had known her killer and willingly let them inside her home. Several fibres found on Heather's body were believed to have come from gloves the killer wore, supported by the fact not a single foreign fingerprint was uncovered. Coupled with the apparent change of shoes, this evidence led police to the conclusion the murder
据推测，凶手很可能在离开公寓前，将沾满鲜血的鞋子换成了一双他们随身带来的更干净的鞋子。调查人员对犯罪现场进行了彻底搜查，并宣布没有丢失任何东西，排除了袭击是由盗窃驱动的可能性。此外，海瑟的前门钥匙插在内部锁孔里，并且没有强行闯入的迹象，这表明她认识凶手并自愿让他们进屋。在海瑟身上发现的几根纤维被认为来自凶手戴的手套，这一点得到了现场没有发现哪怕一枚外来指纹的事实的支持。加上明显更换了鞋子的行为，这些证据使警方得出结论：谋杀
was a carefully planned ritualistic attack. The killer had likely arrived to the scene armed with a full change of clothes, anticipating the amount of bloodshed. However, they had left behind one clue. Draped over a chair in Heather's sewing room was a green hand towel that didn't belong to her family. It was stained with Heather's blood and given its location and positioning, investigators determined it had been placed on the chair after it had received the blood stains. The killer likely brought the towel to the flat and used it to wipe Heather's blood from their face or hands before changing their shoes and clothing and leaving the scene. The national criminal database was used to search for all sex offenders and people with a serious
是一起经过精心策划的仪式性袭击。凶手很可能带着全套换洗衣物到达现场，预料到了流血的程度。然而，他们留下了一个线索。搭在海瑟缝纫室椅子上的是一条绿色的擦手毛巾，不属于她的家人。它沾满了海瑟的血，鉴于其位置和摆放方式，调查人员确定它是沾染血迹后被放在椅子上的。凶手很可能是把毛巾带到公寓里，用来擦掉脸上或手上的海瑟的血，然后换下鞋子和衣服并离开现场。警方利用全国犯罪数据库搜查了海瑟家方圆五英里内的所有性犯罪者和有严重
criminal record within a five mile radius of Heather's home, but all were able to provide solid alibis for the day of her murder. Investigators doorknocked the area and discovered no one who was home at the time of Heather's murder had witnessed anything suspicious or heard any screams, which was unusual given her home was in a busy area surrounded by several other flats. Given it appeared she had willingly let the attacker inside her home, investigators suspected the killer was likely someone close to the family and honed their suspicions in on Heather's ex-husband David, but could find no evidence to link him to the crime. Meanwhile, the results of DNA testing conducted on the strands of hair found in Heather's hands came back. It was initially assumed Heather
犯罪记录的人，但所有这些人都为她被谋杀的那天提供了坚实的有不在场证明。调查人员在当地进行挨家挨户的走访，发现海瑟被谋杀时在家的人中没有人目击到任何可疑情况或听到任何尖叫声，鉴于她的家位于一个周围环绕着几栋其他公寓的繁忙地区，这很不寻常。鉴于她似乎是自愿让袭击者进屋的，调查人员怀疑凶手很可能是熟悉她家的人，并将怀疑目标锁定在海瑟的前夫大卫身上，但找不到任何证据将他与这起犯罪联系起来。与此同时，对在海瑟手中发现的头发样本进行的DNA测试结果出来了。最初人们认为海瑟
had ripped the hair from her attacker's head as she fought for her life, with investigators hopeful they may be able to identify her killer through mitochondrial DNA. But forensic tests revealed something unexpected. The hair had not been ripped out at all, but instead cut neatly with a sharp instrument. Whilst the hair in Heather's left hand was revealed to be her own, the nine centimeter long strands of neatly cut hair in her right hand were identified as belonging to another woman. Further scientific testing of the hair using a process known as stable isotope analysis revealed the unknown female lived in the United Kingdom, but had traveled to Spain or Southern France and Florida less than three months before her hair had been cut. With such detailed analysis,
在为生命搏斗时从袭击者头上扯下了头发，调查人员希望能够通过线粒体DNA识别出凶手。但法医测试揭示了一些意想不到的事情。这些头发根本不是被扯下来的，而是用利器整齐地剪下来的。虽然海瑟左手中的头发被证实是她自己的，但她右手中9厘米长的整齐剪下的头发被确认属于另一名女性。使用被称为稳定同位素分析的方法对头发进行的进一步科学测试显示，这名未知的女性住在英国，但在她的头发被剪掉不到三个月前曾前往西班牙或法国南部以及佛罗里达州。凭借如此详细的分析，
police were confident this hair would help lead them to Heather's killer. Detectives questioned Heather's children and discovered that about a week before the murder, the spare key to their house had gone missing. As she was on a tight income and couldn't afford to risk any of their possessions being stolen, Heather had the locks replaced. When asked if anyone had visited their flat recently, Terry explained one of their neighbors had stopped by a few days prior to his mother's death to inquire about having some curtains made for his girlfriend. It was the same neighbor who had consoled Terry and his sister upon the discovery of their mother's mutilated body, an Italian man he knew as Danny.
警方确信这根头发将有助于他们找到海瑟的凶手。侦探们盘问了海瑟的孩子，发现就在谋杀案发生前大约一周，他们家的备用钥匙不见了。由于她手头紧，无法承担任何财产被盗的风险，海瑟把锁换了。当被问及最近是否有任何人拜访过他们的公寓时，特里解释说，就在他母亲死前几天，一位邻居曾顺道拜访，询问关于为他的女朋友制作一些窗帘的事。正是这位邻居在发现他们母亲残缺的尸体时安慰了特里和他的妹妹，一个他认识的叫丹尼的意大利人。
Danilo Restivo, known to neighbors simply as Danny, had relocated to the United Kingdom in May of 2002 to live with an Italian woman named Fiamma, whom he had met on the internet. Their home was directly across the street from Heather Barnett's, overlooking her bedroom and bathroom. As Restivo didn't speak much English, he immersed himself within the Bournemouth Italian community, frequenting the restaurants and bars that gave him a sense of his home country. He and Fiamma mostly kept to themselves, communicating in Italian and shutting themselves off from their neighbors. Restivo had recently enrolled in a computer course at a local training center where he was also learning English to improve his chances of gaining employment in his
达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃（Danilo Restivo），邻居们简单地叫他丹尼，于2002年5月搬到英国，与他在网上认识的一名名叫菲亚玛（Fiamma）的意大利女子同住。他们的家在海瑟·巴内特家的正街对面，俯瞰着她的卧室和浴室。由于雷斯蒂沃不太会说英语，他融入了伯恩茅斯意大利人社区，经常去那些让他有家乡感的餐馆和酒吧。他和菲亚玛大多独来独往，用意大利语交流，与邻居们隔绝开来。雷斯蒂沃最近在当地一家培训中心注册了一门计算机课程，同时也在那里学习英语，以增加他在
new country. Police had already questioned Restivo in the early stages of Heather Barnett's murder investigation, as he and Fiamma were the first on the scene to help her children. They had embraced Terry and Kaelan and taken them into their flat for support whilst they waited for the police to arrive, but didn't offer any information that could help detectives with their investigation. Five days after Heather's murder, detectives visited her neighbors to request DNA samples as part of a process of elimination. Restivo and Fiamma obliged, providing fingerprints, hair samples and mouth swabs. A detective then asked to see the pair of shoes Restivo was wearing on the day of the murder. Although he hesitated at first, he led the
新国家获得就业机会的机会。海瑟·巴内特谋杀案调查的早期阶段，警方就已经盘问过雷斯蒂沃，因为他和菲亚玛是第一批赶到现场帮助她的孩子的。他们拥抱了特里和凯兰（Kaelan），并将他们带到自己的公寓里给予支持，同时等待警察到来，但没有提供任何能帮助侦探调查的信息。海瑟被谋杀五天后，侦探们拜访了她的邻居，要求提供DNA样本作为排除法的一部分。雷斯蒂沃和菲亚玛予以配合，提供了指纹、头发样本和口腔拭子。随后一名侦探要求查看雷斯蒂沃在谋杀案当天穿的那双鞋。尽管他一开始有些犹豫，但还是把
detective to the bathroom where a pair of size 9 Nike sneakers were soaking in a bucket full of bleach. Restivo explained the shoes were dirty with a bad smell and he was attempting to clean them, but the detective was immediately suspicious and confiscated the shoes for further testing. However, they didn't reveal a match to the bloody footprints in Heather's house. Restivo was brought in for police questioning and asked about his whereabouts on the morning of November 12th, the day Heather was killed. He explained he had left the house between 8.10 and 8.20 am to catch the bus to his computer training centre, where he had attended his classes as usual, before leaving for the day around 3.45 pm. Police looked into his alibi
侦探带到了浴室，那里有一双9码的耐克运动鞋正泡在一桶漂白剂中。雷斯蒂沃解释说鞋子很脏而且有异味，他正试图清洗它们，但侦探立即起疑并没收了鞋子以便进一步检测。然而，它们并没有显示与海瑟屋里的血腥足迹相匹配。雷斯蒂沃被带到警察局接受盘问，并被问及11月12日上午（海瑟被杀的那天）他的行踪。他解释说自己在早上8点10分到8点20分之间离开家，去赶去往计算机培训中心的公交车，他在那里像往常一样上了课，然后在下午3点45分左右离开。警方调查了他的不在场证明，
and discovered it checked out. Restivo had a bus ticket stamped at 8.44 am. Heather's car had been captured on CCTV footage returning home from the school run at 8.37 am, meaning he couldn't have been at her house at the time of the murder. Furthermore, records obtained that Restivo's education facility confirmed he had signed in for his computer classes at 9 am, as stated in his police report. With his alibi in check and no motive for Restivo to want to harm Heather, investigators returned their focus to other potential suspects, including Heather's ex-husband. Detective Superintendent Phil James described the case as one of the most traumatic murders you can imagine, saying, This was a very carefully planned killing. There was nothing spur
发现经得起推敲。雷斯蒂沃有一张在上午8点44分打过戳的车票。海瑟的车被闭路电视拍到于上午8点37分从接送孩子上学的途中回家，这意味着他在谋杀发生时不可能在她家。此外，从雷斯蒂沃的教育机构获得的记录证实，他在上午9点签到了计算机课，正如他的警方报告中所述。随着他的不在场证明得到核实且没有雷斯蒂沃想要伤害海瑟的动机，调查人员将焦点重新转回其他潜在嫌疑人，包括海瑟的前夫。侦探总督察菲尔·詹姆斯将此案描述为你能想象到的最痛苦的谋杀案之一，他说：“这是一起经过精心策划的谋杀。其中没有任何一时
of the moment about it. This was an attack personal to Heather, not the work of a random killer. By early 2003, detectives had questioned over 100 people known to Heather, but not a single one could identify anyone who may hold a grudge against the mother of two, or have a reason to want to harm her. With very few leads to go by, police set out to find the weapons used in the murder. They searched parks, backyards, sheds, rubbish bins, and sewers around the Bournemouth area for the hammer and knife, but to no success. Posters featuring Heather's photo were plastered around town, appealing for anyone with information about her killer to come forward. Whilst a £10,000 reward was offered by crime stoppers,
冲动。这是一起针对海瑟个人的袭击，而不是随机杀手所为。”到2003年初，侦探们已经盘问了超过100名认识海瑟的人，但没有一个人能指出任何可能对这位两个孩子的母亲怀有怨恨或有理由想要伤害她的人。由于几乎没有什么线索可循，警方着手寻找谋杀中使用的武器。他们在伯恩茅斯周围的公园、后院、棚屋、垃圾桶和下水道中搜寻锤子和刀，但没有成功。印有海瑟照片的海报贴满全城，呼吁任何掌握关于她凶手线索的人挺身而出。同时犯罪制止组织悬赏1万英镑，
for anyone who had information that led to a conviction. In May 2003, police searched through Heather's computer and discovered she had sent an email to a friend the week before her murder, in which she mentioned that her spare house keys were missing. She had been unable to find them after a visit from a neighbour who inquired about her seamstress services, and she suspected he may have picked them up by mistake. She left a note in their letter box asking to have the keys returned. That neighbour was Danilo Rostevo. Other than the suspicious bleach-stained sneakers, police had little reason to suspect Rostevo had any involvement in Heather's murder, viewing him as an awkward and clumsy man incapable
奖励任何提供导致定罪线索的人。2003年5月，警方搜查了海瑟的电脑，发现她在谋杀前一周给一位朋友发过一封电子邮件，其中她提到她的备用家门钥匙不见了。她在一位询问过她裁缝服务的邻居来访后一直找不到钥匙，她怀疑对方可能拿错了。她在他们的信箱里留了一便条，要求归还钥匙。那个邻居就是达尼洛·罗斯特沃（Rostevo）。除了那双可疑的沾有漂白剂的运动鞋外，警方没有什么理由怀疑罗斯特沃参与了海瑟的谋杀，认为他是一个笨拙且笨手笨脚、无法
of such a sophisticated attack. Now curious as to whether they may have missed a crucial detail, they ran an online search for his name and made the startling discovery. This wasn't the first time Rostevo had been a person of interest in a major police investigation. More than a decade earlier, he'd been a prime suspect in the 1993 disappearance of 16-year-old Italian teenager, a laser collapse. Investigators revisited Rostevo's alibi at the time of Heather Barnett's murder and realised that it wasn't as airtight as they had initially thought. They double-checked the sign-in book at his computer training centre, where it became evident that on the morning Heather was attacked, his sign-in time had been altered.
遭受如此复杂的袭击。现在，他们好奇自己是否漏掉了某个关键细节，于是对他的名字进行了网络搜索，并做出了惊人的发现。这并不是罗斯蒂沃第一次成为重大警察调查的关注对象。十多年前，他曾是1993年16岁意大利少女激光坍塌（应指埃利萨·克拉普失踪案，此处原文机器翻译失真，但按译文风格处理）失踪案的主要嫌疑人。调查人员重新审视了罗斯蒂沃在海瑟·巴尼特遇害时的不在场证明，并意识到它并不像他们最初想象的那么无懈可击。他们仔细核对了他在计算机培训中心的签到簿，结果显示，在海瑟遇害的当天，他的签到时间被修改过了。
Rostevo had signed in at 9am, but closer inspection revealed the entry had been amended from its original time of 10.28am. Furthermore, although Rostevo's bus ticket had been stamped at 8.44am, there was nothing to confirm whether he had travelled all the way to the training centre, or simply disembarked at the next stop and walked the short track back to Heather's house. For the second time in his life, Danilo Rostevo became a prime suspect, and yet again, the evidence against him was purely circumstantial. There was no motive, murder weapon, or forensic evidence linking him to the Heather Barnett crime scene, and therefore, not enough to warrant an arrest. Police continue to appeal for information,
罗斯蒂沃是在上午9点签到的，但仔细检查发现，该条目的原始时间10点28分已被修改。此外，尽管罗斯蒂沃的公交车票是在上午8点44分打卡的，但没有任何东西可以确认他是直达培训中心，还是只是在下一站下车，然后沿着小路步行返回海瑟的家。达尼洛·罗斯蒂沃一生中第二次成为主要嫌疑人，然而针对他的证据仍然纯粹是间接证据。没有动机、凶器或将他与海瑟·巴尼特犯罪现场联系起来的法医证据，因此不足以签发逮捕令。警方继续呼吁提供信息，
and by the one-year anniversary of Heather's death in November 2003, they released additional details about her murder to the public for the first time, including the killer's Nike sneaker prints and the gruesome dismemberment of her breasts. When the public appeals generated no further leads, they re-honed their focus on Danilo Rostevo. International criminal police organisation Interpol made contact with Italian authorities in Patanza. They notified them that they were looking into Rostevo as a person of interest in Heather Barnett's murder, and requested any information in relation to his possible involvement
并且在海瑟于2003年11月逝世一周年之际，他们首次向公众公布了有关她谋杀案的更多细节，包括凶手的耐克运动鞋鞋印以及她乳房被残忍肢解的细节。当公开呼吁没有产生进一步的线索时，他们将注意力重新集中在达尼洛·罗斯蒂沃身上。国际刑事警察组织（国际刑警组织）与帕坦察的意大利当局取得了联系。他们通知他们，他们正在调查罗斯蒂沃作为海瑟·巴尼特谋杀案的关注对象，并要求提供与他可能参与
in Elisa Clapp's disappearance. They were informed of Rostevo's reported hair cutting fetish and previous criminal behaviour, which only served to highlight him as a likely suspect for Heather's death. In April 2004, police placed Rostevo under surveillance, where they soon discovered the Italian had some disturbing habits. On several occasions, he visited Throop Mill Park, a secluded and isolated park just outside of Bournemouth that was frequented by female joggers. During his visits, Rostevo made efforts to appear inconspicuous, dressing in dark clothing, sunglasses and gloves, with the hood of his jacket often pulled tight around his face. On May 11, 2004, Rostevo parked his car at the end of a quiet
埃利萨·克拉普失踪案相关的任何信息。他们被告知了罗斯蒂沃据称的剪发恋物癖和先前的犯罪行为，这只会使他成为海瑟之死的最大嫌疑人。2004年4月，警方对罗斯蒂沃实施了监控，他们很快发现这个意大利人有一些令人不安的习惯。在几个场合，他参观了特鲁普米尔公园（Throop Mill Park），这是一个位于伯恩茅斯郊外、经常有女性慢跑者光顾的偏僻而孤立的公园。在访问期间，罗斯蒂沃努力表现得不引人注目，身穿深色衣服、墨镜和手套，夹克的风帽常常紧紧拉在脸上。2004年5月11日，罗斯蒂沃将车停在一个安静的地方
laneway near Throop Mill Park, where surveillance officers recorded him changing into a new shirt and shoes. His movements were stealth, and he appeared to be attempting to go unnoticed, as he crouched behind some tall grass and observed a female jogger go past. The next day, May 12, Rostevo returned to Throop Mill Park wearing waterproof trousers. He continued to act suspiciously, and fears increased that he intended to launch an attack. Police decided they couldn't take the risk, and approached Rostevo under the guise they were inquiring about some thefts in the area. He appeared sweaty and agitated as police commenced the search of his vehicle, where they discovered garbage bags, scissors, gloves, a balaclava,
特鲁普米尔公园附近的小巷尽头，监控人员记录下他换上了一件新衬衫和鞋子。他的动作很隐秘，似乎试图不被察觉，他蹲在一些高高的草丛后面，观察着一名女慢跑者从旁边跑过。第二天，即5月12日，罗斯蒂沃穿着防水裤回到了特鲁普米尔公园。他继续表现得形迹可疑，人们越来越担心他打算发动袭击。警方决定不能冒这个险，以询问该地区发生的一些盗窃案为由接近了罗斯蒂沃。当警方开始搜查他的汽车时，他显得汗流浃背、情绪激动，并在车里发现了垃圾袋、剪刀、手套、巴拉克拉法帽（头套），
and a bag containing a large knife. Rostevo explained that he found the knife at the park, and had collected it to ensure it wouldn't harm any children. But police surveillance had captured him conducting no such action. A subsequent search of his house confirmed a blade of the same description was missing from a knife block in his kitchen. A month and a half later, on June 22, Danilo Rostevo was placed under arrest in relation to Heather Barnett's murder. He underwent intense police interrogation over his whereabouts on the day of her death, as well as his suspicious behaviour in Throop Mill Park. He was also pressed about Elisa Clapp's disappearance, but he remained stoic and stuck to all of his original
和一个装有一把大刀的袋子。罗斯蒂沃解释说，他在公园里找到了这把刀，并把它收集起来以确保它不会伤害任何儿童。但警方监控显示他根本没有采取任何此类行动。随后对他的房屋进行的搜查证实，他厨房的刀架上不见了一把同等描述的刀。一个半月后的6月22日，达尼洛·罗斯蒂沃因海瑟·巴尼特谋杀案被捕。他接受了警方关于她遇害当天行踪以及他在特鲁普米尔公园可疑行为的严格审讯。他还被追问关于埃利萨·克拉普失踪的事，但他表现得坚忍不拔，并坚持他所有的原始
stories. After three days of questioning, he was released after police failed to obtain any incriminating evidence to charge him. One detective remarked, I reckon he must have had his nerves extracted when he lost his milk teeth. On a scale of 0 to 10, I never saw fear in his eyes rise above zero. Meanwhile, 1400 miles away in Potenza, Gildor Clapp's had never given up searching for his missing youngest sister. Two years prior had marked a decade since Elisa's disappearance, with all the local churches, except for the Church of the Holy Trinity, commemorating the solemn anniversary by simultaneously ringing their bells in the teenager's honour.
说辞。经过三天的审讯，由于警方未能获得任何可以起诉他的 incriminating（罪证）证据，他被释放了。一位侦探评论道：“我估计他在换乳牙时神经就被切除了。从0到10的等级来看，我从未看到他眼中的恐惧上升到零以上。”与此同时，在1400英里外的波坦察，吉尔多·克拉普（Gildor Clapp's）从未停止寻找他失踪的小妹妹。两年前标志着埃利萨失踪十周年，当地所有的教堂，除了圣三一教堂外，都通过同时敲响钟声来纪念这个庄严的周年纪念日，以向这位少年致敬。
When Gildor learned that Danilo Rostevo had been arrested in the UK in relation to the murder of Heather Barnett, he travelled to Bournemouth to meet with the detectives in charge of the investigation, relaying all the information he knew about their suspect. Upon his return to Potenza, Gildor plastered posters throughout the city, featuring photos of Heather and Elisa side by side. Atop the words, we will remember them. The possible connection between the two cases quickly gathered media attention, with Elisa's mother, Filomena, commenting to the press. The person who took my little girl away from me 11 years ago also took Heather from her children. I wish I could see them. When I heard of her death, my first thoughts were for the children.
当吉尔多得知达尼洛·罗斯蒂沃在英国因海瑟·巴尼特谋杀案被捕时，他前往伯恩茅斯会见了负责调查的侦探，转达了他所知道的关于他们的嫌疑人的所有信息。回到波坦察后，吉尔多在全市张贴了海报，上面印有海瑟和埃利萨并肩的照片。上面写着：“我们会记住他们。”这两起案件之间可能存在的联系迅速引起了媒体的关注，埃利萨的母亲菲洛梅娜向媒体发表了评论。“11年前带走我的小女孩的人也从她的孩子身边带走了海瑟。我真希望我能见到他们。当我听到她的死讯时，我的第一想法就是那些孩子。”
I can imagine what they are going through. I think I can understand how they feel having lost a loved one, just like me. I feel a bond with them. Later in 2006, a plaque was erected on the street Elisa had traversed on her way to the Church of the Holy Trinity the day she went missing. It declared, along this route on September 12, 1993, Elisa claps disappeared. At a distance of 13 years, the city remembers Elisa and awaits the truth. Bornmouth detective started working closely with authorities in Italy, convinced the potential connection between Heather and Elisa's cases was too strong to ignore. As news reports circulated throughout Dorset County, several young women came forward to report having their hair snipped off whilst traveling on public
我可以想象他们正在经历什么。我想我能理解他们失去亲人的感受，就像我一样。我和他们有一种联系。2006年晚些时候，在埃利萨失踪那天前往圣三一教堂途中穿过的那条街上竖立了一块牌匾。上面写着：“沿着这条路线，在1993年9月12日，埃利萨·克拉普失踪了。13年过去了，这座城市记住了埃利萨，并等待着真相。”伯恩茅斯的侦探开始与意大利当局密切合作，确信海瑟和埃利萨案件潜在的联系太强而无法忽视。随着新闻报道在多塞特郡流传开来，几名年轻女性挺身而出，报告说她们在乘坐公共交通工具时头发被剪掉了
transport and in cinemas, with the incidents beginning in 2002 when Restivo first moved to the area. Furthermore, several of these women identified the Italian as the perpetrator of these acts. Whilst the majority of the stories simply involved Restivo surreptitiously chopping locks of the girl's hair, more extreme reports alleged that he was also masturbating underneath his coat whilst doing so. Women in Potenza began reporting similar incidents they had endured many years before, with 24 women in total coming forward across both countries. Restivo's haircutting fetish was a major concern for Bornmouth detectives, who suspected his obsession had something to do with the mysterious lock of hair that had
交通工具和电影院里，这些事件始于2002年雷斯蒂沃刚搬到该地区的时候。此外，其中几名女性认出这个意大利人就是这些行为的肇事者。虽然大多数故事只涉及雷斯蒂沃秘密地剪掉女孩的一缕头发，但更极端的报道声称，他在这样做的同时还在大衣底下手淫。波坦察的女性开始报告多年前她们曾忍受过类似事件，两国共有24名女性挺身而出。雷斯蒂沃的剪发恋物癖是伯恩茅斯侦探的一个主要担忧，他们怀疑他的痴迷与留下的神秘一缕头发有关
been left in Heather Barnett's hand. Each of the women who reported having their hair cut by Restivo agreed to provide DNA samples to test against the mystery hair, but none of the results returned a match. Bornmouth detectives consulted with the FBI, who concluded Heather Barnett's murder was not random but carefully planned, describing her killer as a semi-reclusive but otherwise seemingly regular middle-aged man who exhibited stalker-like behavior. In November 2006, police obtained a warrant to search Restivo's flat. Inside a chest of drawers, they discovered a lock of hair tied with a piece of cotton hidden inside a plastic bag. The hair was tested for DNA, but returned no match for Restivo, Elisa claps, or Heather Barnett.
留在海瑟·巴尼特的手中。每一个报告头发被雷斯蒂沃剪掉的女性都同意提供DNA样本来与神秘头发进行对比，但没有一个结果返回匹配。伯恩茅斯侦探咨询了联邦调查局（FBI），联邦调查局得出结论，海瑟·巴尼特的谋杀不是随机的，而是经过精心策划的，并将她的凶手描述为一个半隐居但看起来很正常的表现出类似跟踪狂行为的中年男子。2006年11月，警方获得搜查令搜查雷斯蒂沃的公寓。在一个抽屉柜里，他们发现了一缕用棉线系着藏在塑料袋里的头发。这缕头发被进行了DNA检测，但没有与雷斯蒂沃、埃利萨·克拉普或海瑟·巴尼特相匹配。
As the plastic bag also contained photos of his partner Fiamas family, it was determined that the hair most likely served as an innocent memento from a family member and was not associated with anything criminal. Despite the unwavering efforts of police, the investigation into Heather Barnett's murder languished. The case continued to be featured in sporadic news articles and on the BBC television show Crime Watch, which generated new leads and potential witness sightings, but nothing substantial enough to warrant Danilo Restivo or any other individual being charged with the murder. In 2006, CCTV footage was aired on Crime Watch which showed a blurry image of an unknown man crossing the street towards Capston Road where Heather lived at 9.24 am on the morning
由于塑料袋里还存有他的伴侣菲亚马（Fiama）家人的照片，因此确定这缕头发很可能只是来自家庭成员的无辜纪念品，与任何犯罪活动无关。尽管警方做出了坚定不移的努力，但对海瑟·巴尼特谋杀案的调查还是陷入了停滞。该案继续出现在零星的新闻报道中，并出现在英国广播公司（BBC）的电视节目《犯罪观察》（Crime Watch）上，这产生了新的线索和潜在的目击者，但没有实质性到足以 warrant（授权）以谋杀罪起诉达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃或任何其他个人的程度。2006年，《犯罪观察》播出了闭路电视（CCTV）画面，显示在上午9点24分，一个不知名男子的模糊影像穿过街道朝海瑟居住的卡普斯顿路（Capston Road）走去。
of her murder. The TV show appealed for anyone with information about the man in the footage to contact police, prompting a shop assistant at a local pharmacy to come forward and identify the man as one of her regular customers, Danilo Restivo. However, as this witness was already aware that Restivo was a person of interest in Heather's murder, police were dubious as to whether this had influenced her identification. Meanwhile, in Italy, in 2007, a thread was created on Italian community website Popolo Dallorette discussing Elisa Clapp's murder. Over 350,000 people engaged with the site to share theories, rumors and speculations. Many posts defended Danilo Restivo and accused the Clapp's family of running a smear campaign
在她遇害的那天早晨。该电视节目呼吁任何掌握录像中男子信息的人与警方联系，促使当地一家药店的一名店员挺身而出，将该男子确定为她的常客之一——达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃。然而，由于该目击者已经知道雷斯蒂沃是海瑟谋杀案的关注对象，警方对这是否影响了她的辨认持怀疑态度。与此同时，在意大利，2007年，意大利社区网站“Popolo Dallorette”上创建了一个讨论埃利萨·克拉普谋杀案的帖子。超过35万人在该网站上分享理论、谣言和猜测。许多帖子为达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃辩护，并指责克拉普一家发起污蔑运动
to destroy his family's reputation. A private investigator hired by Elisa's family infiltrated the site, discovering that Restivo himself was behind several of the user's accounts. Then, in 2008, advances in technology led to retesting of the mysterious green bloodstained towel found in Heather Barnett's flat. The blood on the towel had already been determined to belong to Heather, but it had long since been speculated that the killer had used the towel to wipe clean their own face or hands. This time, forensic experts were able to test for traces of sweat and skin flakes. Whilst the results were unable to determine with 100% certainty whether the traces came from Danilo Restivo, experts ruled there was only a one in 57,000 chance that the
来摧毁他家族的声誉。埃利萨家人雇佣的私家侦探渗透到该网站，发现雷斯蒂沃本人是几个用户账户的幕后黑手。接着，在2008年，技术的进步导致对海瑟·巴尼特公寓中发现的神秘绿色血迹毛巾进行了重新检测。毛巾上的血迹已经被确定属于海瑟，但长期以来一直有人猜测凶手曾用毛巾擦拭过自己的脸或手。这一次，法医专家能够检测出汗液和皮屑的痕迹。虽然结果无法100%确定这些痕迹是否来自达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃，但专家裁定，这
DNA belonged to someone else. In 2009, Restivo's bleach-soaked Nike sneakers were also subject to advanced forensic testing. Trace elements of blood were uncovered on the inside of the shoes, indicating Restivo had blood on his socks when he placed his feet inside the trainers. This supported investigators' initial theories that Heather's killer had brought a second pair of shoes to change into following the attack. However, the exposure to bleach had rendered it impossible to obtain a DNA profile from the blood. Restivo's explanation as to why he was bleaching his shoes was that he thought the bleach was soap, adding he must have gotten the Italian and English words mixed up. The evidence against Restivo was mounting, but police were determined
DNA属于其他人的几率只有五万七千分之一。2009年，雷斯蒂沃浸过漂白剂的耐克运动鞋也接受了先进的法医检测。鞋内部发现了微量的血液，这表明雷斯蒂沃将脚塞进运动鞋时，袜子上沾有血迹。这支持了调查人员最初的理论，即海瑟的凶手带了第二双鞋在袭击后更换。然而，接触漂白剂使得无法从血液中获得DNA图谱。雷斯蒂沃关于他为什么要漂白鞋子的解释是，他以为漂白剂是肥皂，并补充说他一定把意大利语和英语单词搞混了。针对雷斯蒂沃的证据越来越多，但警方决心
to uncover concrete proof before proceeding with an arrest, knowing a jury could easily deliver a not guilty verdict if presented with the evidence they had obtained so far. Then, on March 17, 2010, something unexpected happened. In Potenza, maintenance workers were undertaking repairs on the church of the Holy Trinity, which had been damaged by leaks throughout the winter season. Two maintenance workers entered a wooden door by the altar and ventured upstairs to the building's attic which overlooked the city. Using a torch to illuminate the dark area, one worker began searching the space for damage when he noticed something lying in the corner of the room behind a pile of rubble.
在继续逮捕之前先找出确凿的证据，因为他们知道如果出示目前获得的证据，陪审团很容易做出无罪判决。接着，在2010年3月17日，意想不到的事情发生了。在波坦察，维修工人们正在对圣三一教堂进行维修，该教堂在整个冬季因漏水而受损。两名维修工人从圣坛旁的一扇木门进入，冒险上楼去到俯瞰全城的建筑阁楼。其中一名工人用手电筒照亮黑暗的区域，在杂物堆后面的房间角落里发现有什么东西躺在那里，正当他开始搜寻空间的损坏情况时。
He shone his light on the object and realised in horror that he was looking at a mummified human body. Police and forensic investigators were called to the scene where inspection of the body and surrounding area revealed several items of well-preserved clothing and jewellery, including a pair of shoes, a necklace and round rimmed eyeglasses. The items were shown to the claps family, who confirmed them to be the items Elisa had worn the day she went missing. The heavily decomposed body was taken for DNA testing, confirming that after 16 years, Elisa claps had finally been found. An autopsy revealed the teenager had been stabbed to nine times in the chest and back before being suffocated. The murder weapon was
他把手电筒照向那个物体，惊恐地意识到自己看到的是一具木乃伊化的干尸。警察和法医被召集到现场，经对尸体及周边区域的勘察，发现了几件保存完好的衣物和首饰，包括一双鞋、一条项链和一副圆框眼镜。这些物品被拿给克拉普斯一家辨认，他们确认这就是埃莉萨失踪当天穿戴的物品。这具严重腐烂的尸体被带去做DNA检测，证实失踪16年之久的埃莉萨·克拉普斯终于被找到了。尸检显示，这名少女在被窒息前，胸部和背部曾被刺了九刀。凶器
likely a pair of scissors, with defence wounds to her hands indicating Elisa had fought against her attacker. Her pants had been cut down the front and sides and her bra had been cut from the front. Bruising around her pelvis indicated she had been sexually assaulted, although no traces of semen were detected. In her hands were two separate locks of neatly cut hair and more bundles also lay alongside her body. It was concluded that Elisa had likely been killed in the attic of the church on the day of her disappearance before her body was dragged into the corner of the room and covered with rubble. Traces of another person's DNA were found and sent to geneticist Professor Vincenzo Pascali at the Catholic University of the Sacred Heart in Rome.
很可能是一把剪刀，手上的防御性伤口表明埃莉萨曾与袭击者搏斗过。她的裤子正前方和两侧被剪开，胸罩也是从前面被剪开的。骨盆周围的淤青表明她曾遭受过性侵，尽管没有检测到精液痕迹。她的手里抓着两束整齐剪下的头发，身旁还散落着更多发束。据推断，埃莉萨很可能是在失踪当天于教堂阁楼被杀害的，随后尸体被拖到房间角落并用瓦砾掩盖。现场发现了另一个人的DNA痕迹，并被送往罗马圣心天主教大学的遗传学家文琴佐·帕斯卡利教授处。
Professor Pascali had strong ties to the Church of the Holy Trinity, and his examination of the crucial unknown DNA at Elisa claps crime scene involved a quick analysis using outdated methods. He promptly ruled the DNA did not come from prime suspect, Danilo Restivo. Seeking a second opinion, the magistrate in charge of the murder investigation sent the DNA to the Department of Scientific Investigations who declared the DNA was indeed a match to Danilo Restivo. Professor Pascali was later convicted of forgery and given an 18-month suspended sentence. As news spread that Elisa claps had been discovered in the very location she was last seen, the people of Potenza flocked to lay flowers, plants and teddy bears at the steps of the Church
帕斯卡利教授与圣三一教堂有着紧密的联系，他对埃莉萨·克拉普斯案发现场至关重要的未知DNA的检测，仅仅是使用过时方法进行的快速分析。他草率地判定该DNA并非来自头号嫌疑人达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃。谋杀案调查负责人法官寻求第二意见，将DNA送往科学调查局，经鉴定该DNA确实与达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃相符。帕斯卡利教授后来被判伪造罪，并被判处缓刑18个月。随着埃莉萨·克拉普斯在最后一次被人看到的地点被发现的消息传开，波坦察的居民蜂拥至圣三一教堂的台阶前，
of the Holy Trinity. Citizens reeled over the reality that for close to two decades, Elisa had been lying in the attic of the very place they had gathered to pray for her. Graffiti sprung up around town blaming the church's former priest, Father Don Mimmi, for covering up the teenager's death. Don Mimmi had passed away two years prior, taking any secrets to the grave. In a meeting with a journalist Tobias Jones for his book Blood on the Altar, another of Potenza's Catholic priests Don Marcello Cotzi said, the claps family have been through great suffering. They've been violated in their emotions. To find the cadaver of her daughter in the church has been a laceration to Filomena's heart,
献上鲜花、植物和泰迪熊。市民们震惊地意识到，近二十年来，埃莉萨一直躺在她失踪前他们曾聚集为她祈祷的地方的阁楼里。镇上出现了涂鸦，指责教堂的前神父东·米米（Don Mimmi）掩盖这名少女的死讯。东·米米已于两年前去世，将所有秘密带进了坟墓。在与记者托比亚斯·琼斯（Tobias Jones）就其著作《祭坛上的血》（Blood on the Altar）进行会面时，波坦察的另一位天主教神父东·马尔切洛·科齐（Don Marcello Cotzi）表示，克拉普斯一家经历过巨大的痛苦。他们的情感受到了侵犯。在教堂里找到女儿的尸体，对菲洛梅娜的心来说是一道撕裂般的伤口，
because she's a woman of faith. She went to that church, went there to pray to the eternal father that she should find her daughter, and all that time in that church Elisa was up there. You can imagine the storm in the heart of her mother. On May 19, 2010, 12 detectives gathered outside Danilo Restivo's red brick home in Bournemouth and placed the 38-year-old under arrest for Heather Barnett's murder. He was handcuffed and led outside, covering his face with a towel and declaring his innocence as he accused the police of harassment. During subsequent police interrogation, he was informed that his DNA had been found on the green towel located inside Heather's home. He had previously denied owning the towel,
因为她是一个有信仰的女人。她去过那座教堂，去那里向永恒的天父祈祷能找到她的女儿，而在这期间，埃莉萨一直都在那座教堂里。你可以想象她母亲内心的风暴。2010年5月19日，12名侦探聚集在伯恩茅斯达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃红砖住宅外，以谋杀海瑟·巴尼特的罪名将这名38岁的男子逮捕。他被戴上手铐带到屋外，用毛巾遮住脸，坚称自己无罪并指责警方骚扰。在随后的警方审讯中，他被告知在海瑟家中发现的绿色毛巾上提取到了他的DNA。他此前曾否认拥有这条毛巾，
but now conceded he had given it to her as a colour sample for the curtains he commissioned her to sew. Restivo was refused a bail and held in custody until the preliminary hearing scheduled later that year. Upon hearing the news of Restivo's UK arrest, Elisa's reclusive father, Antonio, gave his first-ever interview to the Italian media, where he said with bitterness, I don't believe in justice anymore. Ours is a country of buffoons, of clowns, and jokes. The truth doesn't count anymore. Of what interest is it to me? She, Elisa, isn't here today. I won't go to her funeral. I will stay here to mourn her alone. One week after Restivo was taken into custody in the UK, Italian authorities issued a warrant
但现在承认这是他作为窗帘颜色的样品送给她的，而这些窗帘是他委托她缝制的。雷斯蒂沃被拒绝保释，并被羁押至当年晚些时候的预审。听到雷斯蒂沃在英国被捕的消息后，埃莉萨性格孤僻的父亲安东尼奥首次接受了意大利媒体的采访，他痛苦地表示：“我不再相信正义了。我们是一个充满滑稽演员、小丑和笑话的国家。真相已经不再重要了。这对我有什么意义？她，埃莉萨，今天已经不在了。我不会去她的葬礼。我会留在这里独自哀悼她。”在雷斯蒂沃于英国被捕一周后，意大利当局签发了
for his arrest for the murder of Elisa Klaps. The prosecution requested Restivo be granted temporary extradition to face questioning in Italy, but the request was denied pending completion of the UK legal process. The preliminary hearing for Heather Barnett's case commenced on November 8, 2010, where Restivo entered his plea of not guilty. Members of Elisa's family were in attendance, who held onto strong hopes the accused killer would receive a prison sentence in the UK instead of Italy, where they feared he might be able to find a way around the system. On May 4, 2011, Restivo faced trial in the Winchester Crown Court, overseen by presiding judge Justice Ian Burnett. An interpreter was present for the entire duration, translating
逮捕令，指控他谋杀埃莉萨·克拉普斯。检方要求暂时引渡雷斯蒂沃回意大利受审，但该请求在英国法律程序完成前被驳回。海瑟·巴尼特案的预审于2010年11月8日开始，雷斯蒂沃在庭上作无罪抗辩。埃莉萨的家属也出席了庭审，他们怀有强烈的希望，即这位涉嫌杀人的凶手能在英国而不是意大利被判处监禁，因为他们担心他在意大利可能会找到钻法律空子的方法。2011年5月4日，雷斯蒂沃在温彻斯特刑事法院受审，由主审法官伊恩·伯内特（Ian Burnett）主持。一名口译员在整个庭审期间在场，进行
from English to Italian, as television crews gathered from across the UK, Europe, and the United States. Elisa's mother, Filomena, was granted permission to sit in the courtroom instead of the public gallery, so Restivo would be able to see her face. The prosecution had been permitted to present evidence relating to Elisa's murder, telling the jury that whilst they were not required to deliver a verdict in relation to that case, the evidence served to prove that the killings of both victims were so similar that there was no doubt they were both done by the same person. The evidence linking Restivo to Heather Barnett's murder was presented over the course of seven weeks, including the bleach-soaked Nike sneakers, the green towel, the police surveillance videos
英语到意大利语的翻译，同时来自英国、欧洲和美国的电视摄制组也聚集于此。埃莉萨的母亲菲洛梅娜获准坐在法庭内而非公众旁听席上，以便雷斯蒂沃能看到她的脸。检方获准出示与埃莉萨谋杀案相关的证据，并告诉陪审团，虽然他们不需要对该案作出裁决，但这些证据足以证明两起受害者的遇害情况如此相似，毫无疑问都是由同一个人干的。将雷斯蒂沃与海瑟·巴尼特谋杀案联系起来的证据在长达七周的时间里被逐一呈上，其中包括沾有漂白剂的耐克运动鞋、绿色毛巾、蒂鲁普磨坊公园的警方监控视频，
at Throop Mill Park, and the CCTV footage of the man crossing the street towards Heather's house, which one witness had identified as Restivo. To highlight his haircutting fetish and the link to the hair placed in Heather's hands, various women from both Bournemouth and Potenza testified that Restivo had given them unwanted haircuts during bus rides and in cinemas. The prosecution worked to discredit Restivo's alibi, pointing out the training centre's sign-in book had been doctored and arguing the accused could have easily purchased the bus ticket and disembarked straight away to fabricate that he was commuting at the time. They also presented new evidence that had come to light since Restivo's arrest. Forensic computer experts had searched the hard drive of
以及拍到一名男子过马路走向海瑟家的闭路电视画面，一名目击者已辨认出该男子就是雷斯蒂沃。为了突出他的剪发癖好以及与海瑟手中发束的联系，来自伯恩茅斯和波坦察的多名女性出庭作证，称雷斯蒂沃曾在公交车上和电影院里强行为她们剪发。检方致力于推翻雷斯蒂沃的不在场证明，指出培训中心的签到簿曾被篡改，并辩称被告当时可以轻易买下车票然后立即下车，以伪造自己正在通勤的假象。他们还出示了自雷斯蒂沃被捕以来浮出水面的新证据。法医计算机专家搜查了他在2002年11月12日（海瑟遇害当天）在培训中心使用的计算机的硬盘，
the computer he had used at the training centre on November 12, 2002, the day of Heather's murder, which revealed that no human activity was found on the computer between 9.08 and 10.10am that day. Furthermore, in the weeks and months following the crime, the computer had been used to search for information and updates regarding the case, including any reported witness sightings and the £10,000 reward. Italian witnesses and the law enforcement agents were called to discuss the circumstances of a laser-clapsed disappearance and murder, with one forensic expert concluding there were similarities in the way both victims' bras had been cut from the front. Denilo Restivo took the stand, denying being the figure captured on the CCTV footage on Heather's
结果显示，当天上午9点08分到10点10分之间，该计算机上没有任何人工操作活动的记录。此外，在案发后的数周和数月里，这台计算机曾被用来搜索有关该案件的信息和最新动态，包括任何关于目击者的报道以及1万英镑的悬赏。意大利证人和执法人员被传唤出庭，讨论埃莉萨失踪和谋杀案的情况，其中一位法医总结称，两名受害者的胸罩都是从前面被剪开的，这一手法存在相似之处。达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃出庭作证，否认自己是海瑟遇害当天早晨
street on the morning of her murder. When presented with the surveillance team's findings that he appeared to be stalking women in Throop Mill Park, Restivo explained he had only gone there to enjoy the wildlife. He reasoned the balaclava found in his car was to help with his sinus problems and that he had changed clothes in the park due to thyroid issues. To account for any discrepancies in his stories, he claimed he suffered from sleep apnea which had a negative impact on his memory. Under cross-examination, he denied masturbating in public but admitted to the haircutting incidents, saying the habit started as a dare when he was 15 years old. From there, he realised he liked the feel and smell of hair and continued doing it, meaning
被闭路电视拍到出现在海瑟街上的身影。当被出示监控小组的调查结果（即他似乎在蒂鲁普磨坊公园跟踪女性）时，雷斯蒂沃解释说他去那里只是为了欣赏野生动物。他辩称，车里发现的巴拉克拉瓦滑雪面罩是为了缓解鼻窦问题，他在公园换衣服是因为甲状腺问题。为了解释他口供中的种种出入，他声称自己患有睡眠呼吸暂停综合征，这给他的记忆力带来了负面影响。在接受交叉盘问时，他否认在公共场合手淫，但承认了剪发事件，称这个习惯始于他15岁时的一次真心话大冒险。从那时起，他发现自己喜欢头发的手感和气味，于是便一直这样做，
no harm and not realising it was an offence to do so. In a bid to gain sympathy from the jury, he presented himself as a misunderstood and lonely man who just wanted to be loved. His manipulative tactic was obvious, with one Italian reporter remarking, that's always been his strategy. He appears to be like the village idiot and people underestimate him. He's very clever, very wily. On June 30, 2011, the jury of seven men and five women deliberated for five hours before delivering their verdict. After nine years of intense investigation, Danilo Restivo was found guilty for the murder of Heather Barnett. In sentencing, Heather's daughter Caitlin presented her victim impact statement, which read,
自认为并没有恶意，也没有意识到这样做是违法的。为了争取陪审团的同情，他把自己塑造成一个被误解、孤独、只想要被爱的男人。他那操纵人心的诡计显而易见，一名意大利记者评论道：“这一直是他的策略。他表现得像个村里的傻子，人们都低估了他。他非常聪明，非常狡猾。”2011年6月30日，由七名男性和五名女性组成的陪审团经过五个小时的审议，最终做出了裁决。经过九年的深入调查，达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃因谋杀海瑟·巴尼特被判有罪。在量刑阶段，海瑟的女儿凯特琳宣读了她的受害者影响陈述，其中写道：
I used to have nightmares and flashbacks reminding me of the events of November 12. I also don't like going into bathrooms. I used to think that someone might be waiting for me. Now, I just hold a fear of what's behind the bathroom door. It was at that moment that I felt as if my heart had been ripped out. My mom is no longer able to help me celebrate my successes and to pull me through the disappointments. I will never get the chance again to tell her how much I love her and how much I now miss her. I feel a great anger at the accused. Without him, she'd still be here. How could he intrude into our safe and happy family home and then take everything from us
“我过去常常做噩梦和闪回，让我想起11月12日发生的种种。我也不喜欢进浴室。我过去常常以为可能会有人在等我。现在，我只是对浴室门后面藏着什么东西感到恐惧。就在那一刻，我感觉自己的心仿佛被硬生生地挖走了。我的妈妈再也无法帮我庆祝成功，也无法在我遭遇挫折时拉我一把。我将再也没有机会告诉她我有多爱她，以及我现在有多想念她。我对被告感到无比愤怒。如果没有他，她现在还活着。他怎么能以如此恐怖和冷酷的方式闯入我们安全幸福的家庭住宅，然后又夺走我们的一切——”
in such a horrific and callous way? During his sentencing remarks, Justice Barnett declared, The seriousness of this offense is exceptionally high. You knew an 11-year-old girl and a 14-year-old boy would find their mother butchered on the bathroom floor. This feature of the case will haunt those who sat through it. Why you picked Heather Barnett as your victim, I do not know, but it's clear that you did so to satisfy a sadistic sexual appetite. The evidence in this case shows you are a cold, depraved, calculated killer.
“——用这种残酷无情的方式？”在宣读量刑意见时，伯内特法官宣判道：“这起犯罪的严重程度极其恶劣。你明知一个11岁的女孩和一个14岁的男孩会在浴室地板上发现他们被残忍杀害的母亲。案情的这一特点将永远萦绕在所有参与审判的人的心头。你为什么选择海瑟·巴尼特作为你的受害者，我不得而知，但很显然，你这么做是为了满足施虐性的性欲。本案的证据表明，你是一个冷酷、堕落、蓄谋已久的杀人犯。”
Danilo Restivo was sentenced to life in prison with no minimum term. Outside court, Heather's brother Ben expressed his relief at the verdict, saying, Our biggest fear was always that this might happen to somebody else. Restivo has already had eight years of freedom that my sister never had. I've thought about the death penalty, but I think it's too good for him. It seems like the easy way out. I think he's going to have a miserable rest of his life in prison. In Italy on July 1, 2011, almost 18 years after her murder, a white coffin containing a laser-clap body was displayed at her former high school,
达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃被判处终身监禁，不得假释。法院外，海瑟的弟弟本对判决结果表示欣慰，他说：“我们最大的恐惧一直是这可能会发生在大街上的其他人身上。雷斯蒂沃已经享受了8年的自由，而我的姐姐却再也没有拥有过。我想过死刑，但我认为死刑对他来说太便宜了。那似乎是条轻松的出路。我想他在监狱里剩下的日子一定会凄惨无比。”2011年7月1日的意大利，在埃莉萨遇害近18年后，一口装着埃莉萨·克拉普斯遗体的白色棺材被摆放在她曾就读的高中里，
along with an image of her smiling face, as the people of Patanza gathered to pay their final respects. The following day, an outdoor funeral was held in one of the town squares, as the claps family refused to put a laser back inside a church. Over 7000 mourners attended the memorial, including politicians, mares, and officials from nearby towns, with many local businesses shutting down for the duration of the service to honor the teenager's memory. Father Don Marcello Cotti, who had provided unwavering support to the claps family over the years, delivered the service. He gave an impassioned speech about the unjust nature of Elisa's death. Quote, Lord, how was it possible that the life of a just blossoming
旁边放着她微笑着的照片，波坦察的人们聚集在这里作最后告别。第二天，露天葬礼在小镇的一个广场上举行，因为克拉普斯一家拒绝将埃莉萨重新放回教堂内。超过7000名哀悼者参加了追悼会，包括政治家、市长以及附近城镇的官员，许多当地商铺在仪式期间暂停营业，以缅怀这位少女。多年来一直为克拉普斯一家提供坚定支持的神父东·马尔切洛·科蒂主持了仪式。他发表了一篇慷慨激昂的演讲，痛斥埃莉萨之死的不公。他引述道：“主啊，怎么可能让一朵刚刚盛开的生命之花被掐断，然后像被人扔掉的杂草一样在黑暗的角落里腐烂呢？又怎么可能这一切都发生在教堂里？您的教堂，主啊。我们怀着内心巨大的痛苦，想要向您诉说那些宁愿窃窃私语也不愿大声疾呼的人。”
flower was cut off and then left to rot in the dark corner like someone threw away a weed? And how was it possible that all that happened in a church? Your church, Lord. We would like to talk to you, with so much suffering in our hearts, about those who preferred to whisper, rather than shout. Following the service, Elisa's lily-covered coffin was finally laid to rest at the Patanza cemetery, her gravestone declaring, My long journey in the dark has finished on a warm spring day. I am finally home. On November 8, 2011, Elisa claps murder trial was held in Salerno, a port city southeast of Naples. Italian authorities had issued a warrant for Rostevo's extradition from the United Kingdom.
仪式结束后，盖着百合花的埃莉萨棺材终于在波坦察公墓安息，她的墓碑上刻着：“我在黑暗中的漫长旅程终于在一个温暖的春日结束了。我终于回家了。”2011年11月8日，埃莉萨·克拉普斯谋杀案审判在萨尔诺举行，这是一个位于那不勒斯东南部的港口城市。意大利当局此前已发出引渡令，要求将雷斯蒂沃从英国引渡回国。
But as the convicted killer had appealed his conviction for Heather Barnett's murder, the extradition warrant was rejected and the Italian trial proceeded in absentia. Rostevo accepted the prosecution's case and chose not to enter a plea, requesting a shortened right trial, which enabled speedy legal proceedings without any dispute against the evidence. Although the physical and circumstantial evidence against him was overwhelming, the case against him was strengthened when another woman testified that prior to Elisa's death, Rostevo had also invited her to the Church of the Holy Trinity under the guise of wanting to give her a present, just like he had done with Elisa. When he invited the woman up to the attic,
但由于这名定罪杀人犯对海瑟·巴尼特谋杀案的定罪提出了上诉，引渡令遭到驳回，因此意大利的庭审在缺席的情况下进行。雷斯蒂沃接受了检方的指控，选择不做无罪抗辩，而是申请简易审判，这使得法律程序得以迅速推进，且无需对证据产生任何争议。尽管针对他的物证和 circumstantial evidence（ circumstantial evidence 翻译为情理证据或间接证据，这里用“间接证据”）压倒一切，但当另一名女性出庭作证称，在埃莉萨遇害前，雷斯蒂沃也曾以送礼物为幌子邀请她去圣三一教堂（就像他对埃莉萨做的那样）时，针对他的案子变得更加牢固。当他邀请这名女性去阁楼时，
she felt uneasy and left. To the prosecutors, this helped paint a picture of the fade Elisa had likely endured back in 1993. On November 11, 2011, Danilo Rostevo was sentenced to 30 years in prison for Elisa Clapp's murder. Upon hearing the verdict, her family burst into tears. The diocese of Potanza applied to Sue Danilo Rostevo, claiming the murder and investigation had damaged the image of the Church. However, a judge rejected the application on the grounds that the Church of the Holy Trinity had failed to act responsibly. Since Elisa's body had been discovered, the Church had come under heavy scrutiny after it was revealed that in January 2010, two months before Elisa's remains were officially discovered, two cleaners had come
她感到不安便离开了。在检方看来，这有助于勾勒出埃莉萨在1993年可能经受的厄运。2011年11月11日，达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃因谋杀埃莉萨·克拉普斯被判处30年监禁。听到判决后，她的家人放声痛哭。波坦察教区申请起诉达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃，声称谋杀和调查损害了教堂的形象。然而，法官以圣三一教堂未能尽到负责任的义务为由驳回了该申请。自从埃莉萨的尸体被发现以来，教堂就受到了密切审查，此前有消息称，在2010年1月（即埃莉萨的遗骸正式被发现的两个月前），两名清洁工曾在阁楼里
across the body in the attic. They notified the new priest in charge of the Church, who had in turn alerted the bishop. However, the grim discovery had not been reported to the police. When this revelation surfaced, the Church officials claimed ignorance, saying they had misunderstood the information. Whilst it was believed the cleaners didn't come forward to authorities out of fear. In another blow to the Church, a saw had been used to create a hole in the beams above the area where Elisa's body lay, indicating someone within the Church had been aware of the murder and fashioned a means for the smell of her decomposing body to escape. A search of the attic had also revealed a mattress stained with the semen of two unknown men.
偶然发现了尸体。他们通知了教堂的新负责人，后者随后又向主教进行了汇报。然而，这一可怕的发现并没有上报给警方。当这一内幕曝光时，教堂官员却假装不知情，称他们误解了信息。虽然人们认为清洁工没有向当局报案是出于恐惧。对教堂的又一次打击是，有人曾用锯子在埃莉萨尸体上方区域的横梁上锯开了一个洞，这表明教堂内部有人知道这起谋杀案，并为她尸体腐烂散发的气味能够散发出去制造了通道。对阁楼的搜查还发现了一张沾有两名不明男子精液的床垫。
Whilst this was deemed unrelated to Elisa's murder, it indicated the Church had been used for intimate acts, with rumours that former priest Father Don Mimi engaged in sexual activity with men up there. Following the exposure of the Church's dark side, the claps family released a statement to the Italian media which read, Once again, silence entered the tutelage of interests that have nothing to do with Christian values prevail over the piety that one should have for a lacerated corpse. We believe that this havoc definitely puts an entire community on its knees. In March 2012, Restivo's application to appeal his conviction for Heather Barnett's murder was rejected, but he was granted permission to appeal his life sentence. His lawyers argued that
虽然这被认为与埃莉萨的谋杀案无关，但它表明该教堂曾被用于亲密行为，有传言称前神父东·米米曾在那里与男性发生性行为。教堂黑暗面曝光后，克拉普斯一家向意大利媒体发表了一份声明，其中写道：“又一次，维护与基督教价值观毫无关系的利益的沉默，压倒了人们对一具饱受摧残的尸体应有的悲悯。我们认为，这场浩劫彻底让整个社区陷入了瘫痪。”2012年3月，雷斯蒂沃对海瑟·巴尼特谋杀案定罪的上诉申请被驳回，但他获准对无期徒刑提出上诉。他的律师辩称，
it was unfair to his client that the prosecution had been allowed to use evidence from Elisa's murder at Heather's trial, and that in turn, he should at least be given the opportunity to have his sentence changed to include a minimum term. On November 21, 2012, the Court of Appeal overturned Restivo's life sentence, sentencing him to a minimum of 40 years imprisonment instead. Outside court, Heather's brother Ben expressed his disappointment at the decision, saying, I feel the original sentence was a just and right one. Whilst 40 years is long, it does not preclude Restivo killing again on release. Perhaps a whole life sentence would have given Restivo the opportunity to reflect upon what he has done. But somehow, I doubt that
允许检方在海瑟的审判中使用来自埃莉萨谋杀案的证据对他的当事人是不公平的，因此，至少应该给他一次机会，将刑期变更为包含最低刑期。2012年11月21日，上诉法院推翻了雷斯蒂沃的无期徒刑，改判他至少监禁40年。法院外，海瑟的弟弟本对这一决定表示失望，他说：“我觉得最初的判决是公正合理的。虽然40年很长，但这并不排除雷斯蒂沃出狱后再次杀人的可能。或许终身监禁本可以给雷斯蒂沃一个反思自己所作所为的机会。但不知为何，我怀疑这种情况是否会发生。”
this would have ever been the case. With Danilo Restivo now convicted for the murders of Elisa Klaps and Heather Barnett, investigators speculated whether he could be linked to other unsolved crimes. There were several other murders throughout Europe over the years in which female victims had their breasts mutilated, and it was theorized Restivo may have been responsible, but no clear links were established. There was also the disappearance of 27-year-old Korean woman Erika Ranzeman, who had vanished from her home in the northwestern Italian mountain region of Alvstar on April 20, 2003. Erika was never found, and following Restivo's arrest in Bournemouth, police conducted a search of his computer and found that he had saved an image of the missing
随着达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃因谋杀埃莉萨·克拉普斯和海瑟·巴尼特而被定罪，调查人员开始推测他是否还与其它未破案件有关。多年来，欧洲各地曾发生过几起女性受害者乳房被割残的谋杀案，有人推测雷斯蒂沃可能是幕后黑手，但并未确立明确的联系。此外还有27岁韩国女性埃莉卡·兰泽曼（Erika Ranzeman）的失踪案，她于2003年4月20日从意大利西北部阿尔卑斯山区的家中神秘失踪。埃莉卡至今下落不明，在雷斯蒂沃于伯恩茅斯被捕后，警方对他的计算机进行了搜查，发现他保存了一张这位失踪女性的照片。
woman. Most compelling was his potential link to the death of 27-year-old Yong Ok Shin, better known as Okie, a South Korean student who was studying English in Bournemouth. At 3 a.m. on July 12, 2002, just four months prior to Heather Barnett's murder, Okie was walking home on a residential street after a night out with friends. She was just three blocks from Danilo Restivo's home when she was stabbed three times in the back. When paramedics arrived, Okie was still alive and was able to describe her attacker as a man wearing a mask. She was taken to Pool General Hospital, where she succumbed to her injuries shortly after. There was no forensic evidence found at the scene, but residents reported hearing Okie's screams followed by the sound of
最引人注目的是他与27岁韩国女子金玉申（Yong Ok Shin，更广为人知的名字是Okie）之死的潜在联系，金玉申是一名在伯恩茅斯学习英语的韩国留学生。2002年7月12日凌晨3点（就在海瑟·巴尼特遇害四个月前），金玉申在与朋友夜出后沿着一条住宅街道步行回家。当时她距离达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃的家只有三个街区，却在背部被连捅三刀。当护理人员赶到时，金玉申还活着，并能够描述袭击者是一个戴着面具的男子。她被送往普尔总医院，不久后因伤势过重身亡。现场没有发现法医证据，但居民报告称听到金玉申的尖叫声，随后是
a car making a hasty U-turn and fleeing the area. Six weeks after Okie's murder, an informant named Beverly Brown told police that 27-year-old heroin addict Omar Bengwet was responsible for the crime. Beverly claimed she was driving Bengwet and two other men when he asked her to pull over. He proceeded to jump out of the vehicle and attack Okie after she refused his offer to join them. Bengwet was arrested and tried in court twice, but two mistrials were declared after the jury was unable to reach a verdict. The problem was that Beverly Brown was seen as an unreliable witness. She had made false accusations in the past, her stories were full of inconsistencies, and some jurors noted she appeared intoxicated when taking the stand in court.
一辆汽车仓促调头并逃离现场的声音。在金玉申遇害六周后，一个名叫贝弗利·布朗（Beverly Brown）的线人告诉警方，27岁的海洛因吸食者奥马尔·本格特（Omar Bengwet）是这起犯罪的元凶。贝弗利声称，当时她正开车搭载本格特和另外两名男子，本格特要求她把车停下。在金玉申拒绝了他加入的邀请后，本格特随即跳下车对其发动袭击。本格特被捕并在法庭上受审两次，但由于陪审团无法达成一致裁决，两次审判均宣告无效。问题在于，贝弗利·布朗被认为是一个不可靠的证人。她过去曾做过虚假指控，她的说辞充满了前后矛盾，一些陪审团成员指出她在法庭上出庭作证时似乎处于醉酒状态。
In addition, CCTV footage obtained from the area of Okie's murder failed to place Beverly's car at the scene. But following a third trial in January 2005, Omar Bengwet was eventually convicted of Okie's murder. Despite having two subsequent appeals rejected, many continue to believe Bengwet is innocent of Okie's murder, with Danilo Restivo being the real culprit. Like his other victims, Okie was small, dark-haired, and attacked from behind on the 12th day of the month, which some have theorized may hold some significance to Restivo. It was also the 12th day of the month that surveillance police blew their cover in Thrupe Mill Park, as they were concerned he was about to launch another attack. Although the murder weapon used to kill Okie was never recovered, forensic evidence
此外，从金玉申谋杀案现场获取的闭路电视画面未能证实贝弗利的汽车当时在现场。但在2005年1月经过第三次审判后，奥马尔·本格特最终被判谋杀金玉申罪名成立。尽管随后的两次上诉均被驳回，但许多人仍然认为本格特是无辜的，真正的罪魁祸首是达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃。像他的其他受害者一样，金玉申身材娇小、黑发，且在每月的第12天遭到从后方的袭击，一些人推测这可能对雷斯蒂沃有着某种特殊意义。同样是在每月的第12天，由于担心他将发动另一次袭击，监控制度下的警察在蒂鲁普磨坊公园暴露了身份。尽管杀死金玉申的凶器从未被找到，但法医证据
has suggested the blade used was consistent with the knife police confiscated from Restivo, following his suspicious behavior in Thrupe Mill Park. Police also confiscated gloves and a balaclava from Restivo that day. In addition, unknown strands of hair were found on the pavement near Okie's body, but these may have come from a nearby hair salon. Although elements of Okie's murder did not coincide with Restivo's known MO, her attack was conducted at the opening of a narrow, secluded passageway, with theories circulating that Restivo may have intended to drag her there for a prolonged attack that was more fitting with his MO, but he was scared off when Okie started to scream. Omar Benguit is currently serving the 17th year of his prison
表明，所使用的刀刃与警方在雷斯蒂沃因在蒂鲁普磨坊公园举止可疑而对其进行盘查后没收的刀具相吻合。警方当天还从雷斯蒂沃那里没收了手套和巴拉克拉瓦滑雪面罩。此外，在金玉申尸体附近的人行道上发现了身份不明的发丝，但这些可能来自附近的一家美发沙龙。尽管金玉申谋杀案的某些元素与雷斯蒂沃已知的作案手法不完全吻合，但对她的袭击发生在一条狭窄、偏僻的通道入口处，有流言推测雷斯蒂沃本打算把她拖到那里进行更长时间的袭击，这更符合他的作案手法，但由于金玉申开始尖叫，他被吓跑了。奥马尔·本格特目前正在服
sentence for Okie's murder and continues to protest his innocence. Heather Barnett's family have made it clear they do not intend to let the evil actions of Danilo Restivo tarnish their cherished memories of their loving sister and mother, with her two children determined to live a life that would make her proud. During Restivo's sentencing, a statement prepared by Heather's daughter, Caitlin, was read aloud, declaring, I want to be known for who I am, not the daughter of a murder victim. What happened forced me to grow more quickly. I will never get the chance to say I love her or how I miss her. My home has been taken away and often never been back. I have chosen not to be a victim. I want my mum to be
因谋杀金玉申而被判处的第17年刑期，并持续坚称自己无罪。海瑟·巴尼特的一家明确表示，他们绝不让达尼洛·雷斯蒂沃的邪恶行径玷污他们对慈爱的姐姐和母亲的美好回忆，她的两个孩子决心过上能让母亲感到骄傲的生活。在雷斯蒂沃的宣读量刑期间，海瑟的女儿凯特琳准备的一份声明被大声宣读出来，其中写道：“我想因为我是我而被人认识，而不是作为一个谋杀案受害者的女儿。发生的一切迫使我更快地成长。我将永远没有机会说我爱她，或者说我有多想念她。我的家被夺走了，我也常常无法回去。我选择不做受害者。我希望我的妈妈能
proud. Following Restivo's conviction, Heather's sister Denise delivered an emotional statement to the press, which read, We had all looked forward to life getting a bit easier for Heather as the children entered their teens and left her more time for visits and activities away from home. The major sadness for her family is that, through her early death, she missed the joy of watching Caitlin perform on stage, do well in her exams, and develop her career. As Terry was a little older, she had been able to take pride in his mountain bike racing and interest in the technical side of bikes, but missed out on his career and interest in business. She would have been thrilled at the recent arrival of her nephew and of her niece's son,
感到骄傲。”在雷斯蒂沃被定罪后，海瑟的妹妹杰尼斯向媒体发表了一份充满情感的声明，其中写道：“随着孩子们进入十几岁并留给她更多外出拜访和活动的时间，我们曾一度期盼海瑟的生活能变得轻松一些。对她家人而言最大的悲伤在于，由于她过早离世，她错过了观看凯特琳在舞台上表演、在考试中取得优异成绩以及发展自己职业生涯的喜悦。由于特里（Terry）年纪稍大一些，她得以因他的山地车比赛以及对自行车技术的兴趣而感到骄傲，但却错过了他的事业和对商业的兴趣。对于外甥的近期降生以及侄子儿子的到来，她本会感到无比激动，
and would have been busy knitting for them. Heather loved her children very much. She was kind and honest with strong ethical principles which she passed on to Terry and Caitlin. She always worked hard at whatever she did and built up a business on word of mouth and reputation. Heather was feisty, had a deep laugh, and a wicked sense of humour. The years since November 2002 have been difficult, but it has also been a time that has brought out the best in countless people, strangers, and friends alike. We see ourselves as survivors, not victims. The Church of the Holy Trinity in Potenza is now permanently closed. Prior to the discovery of Elisa's body and Ristivo's conviction for her murder, journalist Tobias Jones asked Elisa's
并会忙着为他们织毛衣。海瑟非常爱她的孩子们。她善良、诚实，拥有坚定的道德原则，并将这些传递给了特里和凯特琳。无论做什么她总是全力以赴，凭借口碑和声誉建立起了一番事业。海瑟性格倔强、笑声爽朗、有着令人捧腹的幽默感。自2002年11月以来的这些年虽然艰难，但这也是一段激发无数人（无论是陌生人还是朋友）最好一面的时期。我们将自己视为幸存者，而非受害者。”波坦察的圣三一教堂现已永久关闭。在埃莉萨的尸体被发现以及雷斯蒂沃因谋杀她而被定罪之前，记者托比亚斯·琼斯曾问埃莉萨的
brother Jildo how he managed to keep going. Jildo replied, I made a promise to my sister many, many years ago. I promised I would bring her killer to court. When you've lived with this for so long, it becomes a part of you. I have a lot of fear about what will happen one day if it's all over. Having hunted and battled all those years, it will leave an emptiness when it's all over. Until you have certainty, until you find a body, there's no mourning. You can't work through your bereavement. You can never metabolise your pain. It's a suspension of life. Following Ristivo's guilty verdict years later, Jildo told the journalist,
哥哥吉尔多（Jildo），他是如何坚持下来的。吉尔多回答说：“很多很多年前，我对妹妹许下过一个承诺。我承诺过我会将她的凶手送上法庭。当你与这样的事共存了这么久，它就成了你的一部分。如果这一切终于结束，我内心会有很多恐惧，不知道未来会发生什么。经历了这么多年的搜寻和战斗，当一切结束时，会留下巨大的空虚。在你获得确凿真相之前，在你找到尸体之前，就没有真正的哀悼。你无法度过你的悲痛。你永远无法消化你的痛苦。这是一种生命的悬置。”多年后，在雷斯蒂沃被判有罪后，吉尔多告诉记者：
I don't think, after everything we've been through, that we'll ever be at peace. But she can be. She can finally rest in peace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“经历了我们所经历的一切之后，我认为我们永远不会真正平静。但她可以了。她终于可以安息了。这个单集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。”